I got a good dad joke for the day. You're going to start us with a dad joke today instead of ending with a dad joke? Yeah, just for the cold open. This is the beginning? This is okay? No? All right. Format switch here, listener.
我今天有一个很好的冷笑话。你今天要用冷笑话开场，而不是结尾？对，就当是暖场开场白。这是刚开始？这样行吗？不行？好吧。听众朋友们，节目形式要变一下了。
Let's hear it. How much room is needed for fungi to grow? Boy, you tell me. As much room as possible. Oh, welcome to Smart Lens. Smart Lens. Smart Lens. Smart Lens.
说来听听。菌类生长需要多大空间？你倒是说说看。尽可能大的空间。哦，欢迎来到Smart Lens。
Yeah, Sean, you have any opening bits? I do. I do have something to share. What happened today? Consult your sheet. I have no sheets. Really? I have no sheets. You give no sheet?
肖恩，你有什么开场小段子吗？有的。我确实有些东西要分享。今天发生了什么？看看你的手稿。我没有手稿。真的吗？我没有手稿。你什么手稿都不带？
I give no sheet. I don't give no sheet. But first of all, Jason, you are, well I can't wait for you to come visit, but you are so lucky, Jason. Today in London and tomorrow, it's like. The hottest. No exaggeration, like 100 degrees. Right, and then the day I get there.
我什么手稿都不带。我确实什么都不带。不过首先，杰森，你，虽然我等不及想让你来拜访，但你太幸运了，杰森。今天在伦敦，明天，就像。热得要命。毫不夸张，就像100华氏度（约38度）。没错，然后等我到那儿的时候。
And then they get there, it's 72. I literally just looked at that on the way to this little podcast. You're so lucky. It's brutal. Now how many days are you spending over there with Sean in London? Sean? Just three. Just three. I love that Jason doesn't even know. I know. Now how many days are you spending over there with Sean in London?
等他们到那儿，温度就降到72度了。我刚才在来这个小播客的路上刚好查了一下。你太幸运了。太残忍了。那你打算在伦敦和肖恩一起待几天？肖恩？就三天。就三天。我喜欢杰森甚至都不知道这事。我知道。那你打算在伦敦和肖恩一起待几天？
Just three. Just three. I love that Jason doesn't even know. I know. I go where I'm fucking told. In fact, I'm waiting for my wife to help give me notes on packing. Does she make you a list of what you should pack? She tries, but her big move always is to just kind of walk up behind me while I'm starting to pack and say pleasantly,
就三天。就三天。我喜欢杰森甚至都不知道这事。我知道。叫我去哪我就去哪。事实上，我正等着我妻子帮我出谋划策怎么收拾行李呢。她会给你列个清单告诉你该带什么吗？她会试着列，但她的大招总是趁我开始收拾行李时悄悄走到我身后，然后语气愉快地问，
hey, would you like some help? And I say, no, no, I'm set, thank you, I got it. And then she'll just stand there and she'll watch me. I say, I don't need any help. No, no, I know, I'm just changing. And then she'll just start to like lob, quote, suggestions. And so she ends up packing and controlling. What is she worried about do you think?
嘿，需要帮忙吗？我说，不用不用，我都收拾好了，谢谢，我自己行。然后她就站在那儿看着我。我说，我不需要任何帮忙。不，不，我知道，我只是在换衣服。然后她就会开始像抛球一样，抛出各种所谓的“建议”。所以最后都是她在打包和掌控。你觉得她在担心什么？
Is she worried that you're not going to be have the right thing for the right sit? I don't think she's ever worried about anything. I think I think just her happy place is having just kind of like a nosey hand on on on all sorry hand on things. So yeah, you both know this better than I do. She talks about you more than she talks to me. That's true. That's true.
她在担心你没有带对适合各种场合的衣服吗？我觉得她从不担心任何事。我觉得她的快乐源泉就是把手伸进——对不起，掌控一切。所以，你们俩比我更了解她。她谈论你的次数比跟我要说的话还多。真的。真的。
This is true. I actually know more about your trip than you do. Yes. Tell me, when am I leaving? I don't know, I knew you're leaving tomorrow. Tomorrow night, yeah, tomorrow night. Tomorrow night, yeah. How do you feel about it, Jason? Do you get excited about traveling?
千真万确。其实我对你的旅行了解得比你还多。真的。告诉我，我什么时候动身？我不知道，我只知道你明天走。明天晚上，对，明天晚上。明天晚上，对。杰森，你对此有什么感觉？你对旅行会感到兴奋吗？
No, I can't stand it. I don't understand the concept of leaving the nest that you have deliberately created with all your favorite things to the extent you can get them right around you and in the right spot. I'm super excited to see you too. I just don't, no, I mean, but the concept of leaving a place that you're comfortable to go to a place that's completely foreign to you,
不，我讨厌。我无法理解这样一种概念：离开你苦心经营、塞满你最喜欢的东西、尽可能把它们都摆在你周围合适位置的舒适小窝。我也超级期待见到你。我只是觉得——不，我的意思是，离开一个让你感到舒适的地方去一个对你完全陌生的地方，
I get the whole cultural reach. And expose yourself to other things. But yeah. I mean there's tons of stuff to do here. No, there's tons of stuff to do in London, but not in this house where you just mix. This is what makes you, this is kind of should feed your brain
我能理解那种文化上的接触，去体验不同的事物。但是，好吧。我的意思是这里有成吨的事情可做。不，伦敦有成吨的事情可做，但不是在这个能让你。这就是让你，这应该能滋养你的大脑，
and feed your soul and go to different places and see different things from, that's, look I don't want to get into, but it's kind of the problem with America a little bit. Listen, East Hampton, tell us about what fucking. I go to Sag Harbor, I was there this morning. Can I, were you really? Yeah, I rode my bike to the hardware store.
滋养你的灵魂，去不同的地方，看不同的东西，那个，听着，我不想深入探讨，但这有点像是美国目前存在的一点小问题。听着，东汉普顿，跟我们说说到底。我去萨格港，我今天早上还在那儿。我能，你真的去了吗？对，我骑自行车去五金店。
I fixed my bike. Wait, you rode your bike from East Hampton to Sag Harbor? No, I did not, I didn't do that. It was too hot. That sounds so wrong though. I felt very chore-y today, like I rode my bike into town, I talked to some police officers, said hi to them, they were dealing with an issue,
我修了自行车。等等，你是从东汉普顿骑车去萨格港的吗？不，我没有，我没那么干。太热了。听起来真不对劲。我今天觉得自己像是在做杂务，比如我骑车进城，跟一些警察聊了聊，跟他们打了招呼，他们当时正在处理一个问题，
apparently there was a dog issue. I'm not kidding. Was the dog stuck in a tree? No, like somebody complaining that somebody else had left their dog outside, but it was in a sunny area and was mad and called the East Hampton police. And then had an argument. There's not proper shade for this animal.
显然是一起关于狗的问题。我不是在开玩笑。狗被困在树上了吗？不是，是有人投诉说另一个人把狗留在外面，但当时那地方有太阳，狗很生气，于是给东汉普顿警方打了电话。然后还争论起来了。这动物没有阴凉处。
Yeah, and these cops were so diplomatic about it, because they're just like, what are we dealing, what are we talking about? Do you know what I mean? So they were nice about it. What would that be like getting, no shade, pun intended, being thrown on Hampton cops, but when you decide you want to be a police officer,
对，这些警察对此处理得非常外交辞令，因为他们就像是在说，我们在处理什么，我们在谈论什么？你知道我的意思吗？所以他们态度很好。如果是你，没有阴凉处（双关语），被汉普顿的警察抱怨会是什么感觉，但当你决定想当一名警察时，
what is that, you say, well, I want to be a police officer in the Hamptons because you love the town or because you just don't want the heat, you don't want the nonsense, you don't want a lot of crime. I think a lot of them grow, a lot of the officers I've talked to are local, I grew up here.
那是什么感觉？你会说，嗯，我想在汉普顿当警察，是因为你热爱这个镇子，还是因为你只是不想忍受炎热，不想忍受无聊的废话，不想面对太多的犯罪？我觉得他们很多都在这里长大，我聊过的很多警察都是本地人，我就是在这里长大的。
And I got to say, honestly, to a person, every one of them that I've ever talked to and met has been super, super nice. That's not shocking. Yeah, yeah, they've been really, really nice. Yeah, and that's kind of the consensus. They're super responsive. And imagine the personalities they have to deal with out here.
而且我必须说，老实说，对于每一个人，我曾经聊过、见过的每一个人，都超级超级好。这并不让人震惊。对，对，他们真的非常好。对，大家基本都有这个共识。他们反应超级快。而且想象一下他们在这里必须应付的那些形形色色的人。
Just imagine. Well, yeah, and they're trying to nab those little girls running lemonade stands that are skimming, right? They've got a watch out for them. What's their beat? Skimming. Their beat is, they do everything.
想象一下吧。好吧，是的，他们还要去抓那些在路边摆柠檬水摊、偷工减料的小女孩，对吧？他们得留神这些。他们的片区是干嘛的？偷工减料。他们的片区是，他们什么都管。
You know, they deal with a lot of, unfortunately, there are a lot of issues that happen here. People come on vacation here, so a lot of people feel like no rules, a lot of people drink and drive, which is a terrible thing. It's my worst, honestly, not to get too dark, but the thing I like, the sound I like the least is the sound of obviously an ambulance at night. And you'll hear it late at night, because especially if it was summer way down the, you know, way at the end of the island,
你知道的，他们要处理很多，不幸的是，这里发生了很多问题。人们来这里度假，所以很多人觉得这里没有规则，很多人酒后驾车，这是一件极其糟糕的事。老实说，这让我最头疼，倒不是说要把话题引向黑暗，但最让我受不了的声音，显而易见，就是夜里的救护车声。你会听到深夜里传来的救护车声，尤其是夏天，在岛的最南端，
and that you know that there's been some terrible accident, you read about it in the local paper the next day, and it's just absolutely heartbreaking. It's absolutely heartbreaking. It breaks my heart. It's such a small town. Everybody knows everything. Yeah. But also just like, you know, because people feel like, oh, well, I'm just going to have four glasses of wine and get behind the wheel of my fucking rolls or whatever.
然后你知道肯定发生了什么可怕的事故，你第二天在当地报纸上就能读到，这绝对让人心碎。绝对让人心碎。这让我心碎。这是个如此小的小镇。每个人都知道一切。对。但同时也是因为，你知道的，因为人们觉得，哦，好吧，我只是喝了四杯酒，然后就可以开着我那该死的劳斯莱斯或者别的什么车上路了。
You know, it's sad. It's really, really sad. But also, yeah. Has there been festivities for the Big Jaws anniversary out there, isn't that where they supposedly shot the film? No, that was Martha's Vineyard though. Well, that's close though, right? Oh, right, right, right. But I did see a couple days ago a whale breach about 100 yards off the beach.
你知道的，这很可悲。真的，真的非常可悲。不过话说回来，是的。那儿有什么庆祝《大白鲨》上映周年的活动吗？那不是他们拍电影的地方吗？不，那是玛莎葡萄园岛。好吧，不过那也很近，对吧？哦，对，对，对。不过我几天前确实看到一头鲸鱼在离海滩大约100码的地方跃出水面。
It was unbelievable. Wait, does that mean jump up and slam down to a belly flop? Yeah, like a massive, like just, like just. Are you sure that wasn't a fill in the blank joke here? What fat person you wanna take a run at, Sean? Yeah, I mean who? Go ahead, you can fill in the blank. God bless, no.
太令人难以置信了。等等，那是指跳起来然后以一个腹部着水的方式砸下来吗？对，就像一个巨大的，就像那样，就像。你确定那不是一个填空笑话吗？肖恩，你想拿哪个胖子开涮？对，我的意思是，谁？来吧，你可以填空。上帝保佑，没有。
Oh, God. But I did have something that happened today. Sean, you talk about breaching every time you have sloppy joke, don't you? You're always like, when you're making a run for it. I sure do. We got a breach! Wait, but I do have a really quick medical thing.
哦，天哪。不过我今天确实遇到了点事。肖恩，你每次讲无聊笑话的时候都会提到“跃出水面”，对吧？你总是这样，当你想溜之大吉的时候。我当然会。我们遇到突发状况了！等等，我确实有一个非常紧急的医疗小插曲。
Or do you want me to wait till later? No, give us some of your coffee chat stuff. So, so today, because I'm not feeling well, and so I woke with a sore throat whenever, but so I went to the doctor. Maybe there's something wrong with your CPAP. No, I didn't bring it. What? I didn't bring my CPAP.
还是你想让我等会儿再说？不，跟我们聊聊你的咖啡闲谈吧。所以，今天，因为我感觉不太舒服，我醒来时喉咙痛什么的，所以我去看医生了。也许你的呼吸机（CPAP）出了什么问题。不，我没带。什么？我没带呼吸机。
What? Truly? Truly. Wait, I understand, hold on a second. Don't you need? Because I'm going to sleep on my side or I sleep up now. I don't want to, I can't deal with it. And what do you do, just get like duct taped into position?
什么？真的吗？真的。等等，我明白，等一下。你不需要吗？因为我要么侧睡，要么现在仰睡。我不想，我没法应付那个。那你怎么办，就像被胶带固定在某个姿势上？
Like. Hey, but wait, I've seen a commercial for a guy, he's in a CPAP. Let's lock him up. It's downtime. There's a guy that's in a circle, like a support group for CPAP dudes, and they're all wearing different flavors of CPAPs,
就像。嘿，不过等等，我看过一个广告，有个家伙，他正戴着呼吸机。我们把他锁起来。这是休息时间。有个家伙在一个圈子里，就像是呼吸机男士互助会，他们都戴着各种款式和味道的呼吸机，
and they come to him, and he's just got a clicker. He's got a clicker. What are you talking about? Is yours flavored? He's just got a clicker in his hand got a clapper. What are you talking about? Is yours flavored? He's just got a clicker in his hand and he doesn't have to wear the hose. And so what is that? Have you looked into that?
然后他们走向他，而他手里只有一个点击器。他手里拿个点击器。你在说什么？你的有味道吗？他手里拿个点击器，根本不用戴管子。那到底是什么？你研究过这个吗？
No, I'm not, I have no idea what you just said. Dude, dude looks pretty great and you can avoid the duct tape. Anyway, well whatever. I like the idea of showing that you have it flavored like a watermelon flavor, you know what I mean? Just like a little mist. Well that would be, yeah, that would make it better. Anyway, so. You can hear how low my voice is. So you're sick, you know what I mean? Just like a little bit. Well that would be, yeah, that would make it better.
不，我没有，我完全听不懂你在说什么。老兄，那家伙看起来很棒，而且你还能免于被胶带缠住。不管怎样，随便吧。我挺喜欢那种想象的，把它做成西瓜味什么的，你知道我的意思吗？就像一点点雾化喷雾。好吧，那会，对，那会让事情变得更好。不管怎样，所以。你能听出我的声音有多低。所以你病了，你知道我的意思吗？就像一点点。好吧，那会，对，那会让事情变得更好。
Anyway, so. So you can hear all of my voices. So you're sick, you know? So I go to this doctor at this place and that was recommended, she was fantastic. And so I go in and I'm never, it must be an English thing. I go in and she's like, okay, take your clothes off. And Scotty's sitting there with me.
不管怎样，所以。所以你能听到我所有的声音。所以你生病了，你知道吗？所以我去了这个地方的一位医生那里，那是别人推荐的，她太棒了。所以我走进去，我从来没——这一定是个英国人的习惯。我走进去，她就说，好了，把衣服脱了。斯科蒂正跟我坐在一起。
And I was like, sorry? And she goes, well I gotta check, I gotta check you out. And I was like. Wait, sorry, this is. You want me to just take my shirt off? This is for C-papping? No, this is just, I gotta check you out. And I was like, you want me to just take my shirt off? This is for CPAPing? No, this is just, I have a sore throat. A sore throat?
然后我说，不好意思？她说，嗯，我得检查一下，我得给你检查。然后我说。等等，抱歉，这是。你是想让我直接把衬衫脱了？这是用呼吸机必须的吗？不，这只是，我得给你检查一下。然后我说，你是想让我直接把衬衫脱了？这是用呼吸机必须的吗？不，只是我喉咙痛。喉咙痛？
Yeah, she just wants to check me out. You have a sore throat after one night you go to the doctor? Well, because they're going to go in the other way to make sure that it's not the death of God. They've got to make sure both ends are. Does this person have an office or is it something with wheels? This is in the park?
对，她只是想给我做个检查。你喉咙痛看一次就要去看医生？好吧，因为他们要从另一个方向检查，确保不是什么致命的大病。他们得确保两头都……这个人有办公室还是有什么轮子的车？这在公园里吗？
Sorry, one more time. Carry on. It's next to the ice cream truck. So I go in there and she needed to check me out because I'm a new patient in England, right? And she was like, so I go in there, she asked me to take, I go, you want me to take my shirt off? She's like, yeah. And I go, my pants too. She goes, yeah. So I was like, this I go in there, she asked me, I go, you want me to take my shirt off? She's like, yeah, and I go, my pants too?
抱歉，再说一遍。请继续。就在冰淇淋车旁边。所以我走进去，她需要给我检查，因为我是英国的新病人，对吧？然后她就说——所以我走进去，她让我脱，我说，你想让我脱掉衬衫？她说，对。我说，连裤子也脱？她说，对。所以我当时想——我走进去，她让我，我说，你想让我脱掉衬衫？她说，对，我说，连裤子也脱？
She goes, yeah. So I was like, this is so weird. And so I lay down flat. Luckily it's just a drawstring at all times. So I keep going. So I lay down and she's, you know, she's at the tap on the thing and the tap on the chest and everything, she's checking my thing.
她说，对。所以我当时想，这也太诡异了吧。然后我就平躺下来。幸好一直都只是松紧带。所以我继续。所以我躺下，她开始，你知道的，她在那个东西上拍打，在胸口上拍打什么的，她正在检查我的情况。
And then she's- She's fully clothed right now, right? She's totally fully clothed. She lifts up my underwear and just goes I'm just need to check out testicles She grabs my my balls and I was under your underwear. She doesn't yes She grabs them with her bare hands and I was like Wow what was she able to see through the dust? Did she snap a glove on at least I Don't remember. I think sure you went into a blackout. Yeah, I did. I couldn't believe
然后她——她现在穿着完整的衣服，对吧？她完全穿着衣服。她掀起我的内衣然后直接说我需要检查一下睾丸。她抓住了我的——我的蛋蛋，当时就在你的内衣下面。她没有，是的。她用光手抓住了它们，当时我想——哇，她透过灰尘能看见吗？她至少戴上手术手套了吧？我不记得了。我想你当时一定昏厥过去了。是的，我确实昏厥了。我简直不敢相信
it. I couldn't believe it. So what was the prognosis? No, I'm fine. I'm just not in that. Oh, Scotty heartbroken. I'm straight. Yeah. The prognosis. So just a sore throat. You'll be fine. Yeah, I'm on antibiotics now. I mean. Wow. Okay. What, did you have to feel my balls? Good story.
这一切。我简直不敢相信。那诊断结果是什么？不，我很好。我只是不在那个状态。哦，斯科蒂心碎了。我是个直男。对。诊断结果。也就是喉咙痛。你会没事的。对，我现在在吃抗生素。我是说。哇。好吧。什么，你非得摸我的蛋蛋吗？好故事。
Anyway, go ahead. Um. I just thought that was really odd, like I've never had a doctor do that. Hey, Jay, listen, you got something to look forward to tomorrow night. You're gonna get a sore throat when you get to London. I'll be doctor, I'll play the doctor.
不管怎样，继续。嗯。我只是觉得这真的很古怪，我从来没遇到过哪个医生会这样做。嘿，杰伊，听着，明天晚上你有得期待了。等你到了伦敦，你也会喉咙痛的。我来当医生，我来扮演医生。
Yeah, did you get? Oh, you know the drill now, so don't be surprised. Did you get like a bulk visit type of thing? Is there a punch card that I can use one of those? You know, where you're free visits? Yeah, I'm gradually going to Maro again. All right. Guys, today our guest.
对，你拿到了吗？哦，你现在熟悉这套流程了，所以别大惊小怪的。你拿到那种次卡或者类似的东西了吗？有没有一张打孔卡，我可以免费看病的那种？你知道的，免费看病的卡？对，我慢慢又要去马罗了。好了。伙计们，今天我们的嘉宾。
Oh, it's Chase's guest. Yes, sir. Today our guest is an actor, a comedian, a radio host, and a pioneer in podcasting. In fact, without him, we wouldn't be here. Having released over 1,600 episodes, 600 million downloads during a 16-year run, he has decided to put it to rest
哦，这是蔡斯的嘉宾。是的，先生。今天我们的嘉宾是一位演员、喜剧演员、电台主持人，也是播客领域的先驱。事实上，没有他，我们就不会坐在这里。在经历长达16年、发布了超过1600集节目、获得6亿次下载量之后，他决定功成身退，
to move it onto the next. WTF, WTF. Here to tell us how he did it and hopefully how we can suck a little bit less is the goat himself. Mr. Will? Mark Marin. Mark Marin. Please, Mark, reveal yourself. Oh, man!
开启人生下一阶段。WTF，WTF。今天来到这里，告诉我们他是如何做到的，并希望能教教我们怎么能表现得不那么逊的，就是山羊（GOAT，史上最佳）本人。马尔文先生？马克·马龙（Marc Maron）。马克·马龙。请吧，马克，现身吧。哦，天哪！
So we didn't need to send you a microphone, is that right? When you said we wouldn't be here without, I was immediately, I was like, it's Mark Marin. Yeah, it's not Dax Shepard, although we appreciate. You mean Dax Shepard Marin? Yeah. Wait, you're the dad? We found him. On some level I'm the dad, yeah.
所以我们根本不需要给你寄麦克风，是吗？当你刚才说没有我们就不会坐在这里时，我立刻就反应过来了，心想，这是马克·马龙。没错，不是戴克斯·夏帕德（Dax Shepard），尽管我们很感激。你是说戴克斯·夏帕德·马龙？对。等等，你才是那个爸爸？我们找到他了。
Yeah, you are the dad. And the goat. Yes, yeah. This is awesome. This is real awesome. I'm using my own microphone, but thank you for sending me the one I'll never use. I appreciate that.
在某种程度上我确实是那个爸爸，对。没错，你就是那个爸爸。而且还是山羊（史上最佳）。是的，对。这太棒了。这真的是太棒了。我用的是我自己的麦克风，不过谢谢你们寄给我那个我永远不会用的麦克风。我很感激。
Did we really send you one? Yeah, they sent me one. They were panicked, I guess. They were like, no, no, no. Mark doesn't seem to know what he's doing. Well, they heard you were done with your podcast, they sent yeah, so they said one of these of all Rob turn your mics on what are you doing? Mark Merritt, we were given misinformation. It's like sending a hockey stick to Wayne Gretzky like what are you doing?
我们真的给你寄了一个吗？对，他们寄给我了。我猜他们当时慌了。他们大概觉得，不，不，不。马克看起来好像不知道自己在干什么。好吧，他们听说你不做播客了，就寄了——所以他们寄了其中一个——罗布，打开你们的麦克风，你们在干什么？马克·马龙，我们得到了错误的信息。这就像给韦恩·格雷茨基（Wayne Gretzky）寄一根曲棍球棒一样，你们在干什么？
When I got it, I was like are you fucking kidding me? What am I gonna? You know it is it's our start gift. I appreciate it. We used to send them out during COVID, but we weren't as generous. We put them in a self, you know, you could send it back to us when you were done using it. Sure, well, we're just silly over here.
当我收到它的时候，我当时想，你们是在开玩笑吧？我拿它干什么？你知道的，这是我们的见面礼。我很感激。我们在疫情期间会寄出这些，但那时候我们没这么大方。我们把它放在一个自主，你知道的，你用完之后可以寄回给我们。当然，好吧，我们在这儿就是瞎胡闹。
Well, it's been great. I was listening to the opening. It's, you know, exploring the dark side of luxury problems. Oh, yeah. Super relatable. That's what we are. We try to stay as unrelatable as possible and I think we're doing swimmingly.
好吧，这太棒了。我刚才在听开场白。这，你知道的，是在探讨奢侈带来的烦恼的阴暗面。哦，是的。超级有共鸣。我们就是这样。我们尽量保持最没有共鸣的状态，我觉得我们做得风生水起。
Exciting medical story. I enjoyed that. Yeah. It reminded me of like when I was coming up with this comic, you always had to do morning radio and you'd be sitting there waiting for a break before you'd go in with this morning crew Just figuring out a way in you know hearing what they're talking about. Yeah, and just panicking like I got a story on that I'm gonna start with that
精彩的医疗故事。我很喜欢。这让我想起我刚开始做喜剧演员的时候，你总是得做早间电台，你会坐在那里等待休息时间，然后才能和这个早间团队一起进去，只想找个切入点，你知道的，听听他们在聊什么。对，然后恐慌得不行，心想我得讲个故事，我要从那个切入。
That is the thing that I worry about with this with this silly thing Whatever we're fucking doing is that it's good But is it like it's like morning zoo or whatever like whack even when we get into the questions and the stuff like I don't want to be like a guy who's like obnoxious and always just waiting to let you know that I can make fun of that ship is sailing sorry buddy it's supposed to be a conversation no no morning but zoo I think that's what you know the medium has sort of birthed you know know, just a hundred thousand mediocre afternoon drive time radio hosts.
这就是我担忧这件事的地方——这个愚蠢的东西，无论我们在搞什么鬼——它挺好，但它是不是有点像早间动物园节目之类的那种感觉？——甚至当我们进入问答和那些环节时，我不想成为那种令人讨厌的家伙，总是迫不及待地让别人知道我可以拿那种破事开玩笑——时代变了，伙计，抱歉。它本该是一场对话。不，不，早间动物园式的节目，我觉得这就是——你知道的——这个媒介催生出来的产物，你知道的，只是一大堆平庸无奇的午后车载电台主持人。
I mean, anytime I scroll on my phone on Instagram Reels, it's like three or four white guys talking about the last time they shit their pants as adults. That's us. I listen to that. I listen to that. Mark, talk to us. It's so true.
我的意思是，任何时候我在Instagram Reels上刷手机，总会有三四个白人男士在讨论他们成年后最后一次拉裤子是什么时候。那就是我们。我听那个。我听那个。马克，跟我们聊聊。太真实了。
I know. It's so true. In fact, I think I've told that story, baby. It's either on yours or on Dax's. But wait, talk to us. That's so true. I know. In fact, I think I've told that story maybe either on yours or on Dax's. But wait, talk to us about that. Like, can you reflect? And we'll probably ask you a few times during this about that. Like, what you started is obviously it's an enormous business and path to employment for a lot of folks nowadays. So we collectively can thank you for that.
我知道。太真实了。事实上，我觉得我可能讲过那个故事，宝贝。要么是在你的节目上，要么是在戴克斯的节目上。不过等等，跟我们聊聊这个。太真实了。我知道。事实上，我觉得我可能讲过那个故事，也许是在你的节目上，或者在戴克斯的节目上。但等等，跟我们聊聊这个。比如，你能回顾一下吗？在这次访谈中我们可能还会问你几次关于这个的问题。比如，你开创的事业显然是一个巨大的商业帝国，也为如今的很多人提供了就业途径。所以我们大家都可以为此感谢你。
But how do you feel that it's, are you proud of this sort of industry that you've kind of created? Or is there blood on your hands? Yeah, I don't think, well you know, once you create the bomb, you kind of wash your hands of it. You're Oppenheimer, man, you're Robert Oppenheimer. You know what I mean? But it's morphed away from something that was really
但你觉得这，你为你亲手创造的这种行业感到骄傲吗？还是说你的双手沾满鲜血？是的，我不觉得，嗯，你知道的，一旦你造出了炸弹，你基本上就从这件事里洗手不干了。你是奥本海默，老兄，你是罗伯特·奥本海默。你知道我的意思吗？但它已经从小偷小摸演变成了曾经那种
this one hour conversation or longer. I mean, obviously, Rogan still does that, Dax does it. Oh, they do like three hours, Jesus. I don't know who's watching that shit. It's hard to do that really well. Well, I don't think that there was a single way to do this. The only thing that I know in terms of starting it the way I did, I did it specifically,
一小时或更长时间的对话。我的意思是，很明显，罗根还在做那个，戴克斯也在做。哦，他们要做三个小时，天哪。我不知道谁会看那种破玩意儿。要把那个做好其实很难。嗯，我不认为做这个只有单一的方式。我所知道的关于以我那种方式开始的一切，我做得很专一，
the only way really I knew how and the way that my emotions guided me to do it. And when we started it, there was no real podcast medium. There was a few of them around. It had been around a while. And the way I did it, the way it evolved was just my style and kind of this idea of candid, authentic, vulnerable interviews.
那是我唯一真正知道的方法，也是我的情感指引我去做的方法。当我们开始做的时候，并没有真正的播客媒介。周围只有那么几个。它已经存在一段时间了。我做的方式，它演变的方式，只是我的风格，以及那种坦诚、真实、脆弱的访谈理念。
I think it created a zone through which some people could do that. But I mean, it got more interesting when people were doing full-scale radio shows or crime shows or multi-mic'd guys. It was never, there was never a format other than a mic. full-scale radio shows or crime shows or multi-mic'd guys. There was never a format other than a mic. So because I did it the way I did it, even when you guys, or at least two of you,
我认为它创造了一个地带，让某些人能够做到这一点。但我的意思是，当人们开始做全尺寸的电台节目、罪案节目或者多麦克风访谈时，它变得更有趣了。它从来没有，除了一个麦克风之外，从来没有什么固定的形式。全尺寸的电台节目、罪案节目或者多麦克风访谈。除了一个麦克风，从来没有什么固定的形式。所以因为我是按我的方式做的，甚至当你们，或者至少你们俩当中的人，
sorry Sean, I'm sorry. Just pile on. But when people were coming to my house, it was like, where am I, what neighborhood is this, what are we doing, is there a camera? And it was really, there was nothing binding me to any sort of style or context. But I think because of the reason my timing was good,
抱歉，肖恩，我很抱歉。只管往我身上堆吧。但当人们来到我家时，感觉就像是，我在哪儿，这是哪个社区，我们在干什么，有摄像头吗？老实说，没有什么能将我局限于任何特定的风格或背景。但我认为，由于我的时机很好，
cosmically, for once in my life, that it took off. So this was one way to do it. And I think if anything, my particular way of doing it made a lot of people think, you know, like if that idiot can do it, you know, I'm getting mics. So, there was that. But also, you have to, well, first of all, you brought up,
在宇宙的安排下，我人生中破天荒头一遭，它火了。所以这只是做这件事的一种方式。而且我认为如果说有什么的话，我这种特有的做事方式让很多人觉得，你知道的，如果那个笨蛋都能做到，你知道的，我也要去搞几个麦克风。所以，确实有那种情况。不过话说回来，你得——首先，你提到了，
I mean, you're a comic, and you've been a comic for a long time, and you've been doing it, you know, at the highest level for a long time. So, you know what you're doing. You're a funny dude, and you have to be able to move it along. We're lucky it took three of us to do what you did by yourself.
我的意思是，你是个喜剧演员，你当喜剧演员已经很久了，而且你一直都在，你知道的，以最高水平在做这件事已经很久了。所以，你知道自己在做什么。你是个有趣的家伙，你必须得能掌控节奏。我们很幸运，需要我们三个人才能完成你一个人做的事。
Yeah, exactly. You know? I guess, but the one thing that I was excited about was I wasn't beholden to that. You know, I'd done some time on radio and once I learned how to talk on a mic by myself for long periods of time, that was a pretty big breakthrough. So that kind of served me in the podcast realm.
是的，完全正确。你知道吗？我猜是这样，但我感到兴奋的一点是，我并不受制于那个框架。你知道的，我在电台待过一段时间，一旦我学会了长时间独自对着麦克风说话，那就算是一个相当大的突破。所以这在播客领域对我很有帮助。
But a lot of my monologues are not really funny. They're pretty honest and they're pretty visceral and they are directly related to my life and it gets deeper and sometimes in others, but I wasn't beholden to comedy. So what for me, what it really became was engaging with a person without a real plan to see if we could get a conversation going
但我的许多独白其实并不好笑。它们相当诚实，相当直白，而且与我的生活息息相关，有时会比其他时候更深沉一些，但我并不受喜剧的束缚。所以对我来说，它真正变成的是在没有具体计划的情况下与一个人进行交流，看看我们是否能展开对话，
and figure out where we met in terms of our issues, our problems, our lives and whatnot. So what I was really sort of hoping for was connection. And that's really what I think made what I do kind of different. That there is no sense of. But you did so many firsts. I remember a couple of things that stick out that I remember.
并弄清楚我们在我们的问题、困扰、生活等方面在何处产生了共鸣。所以我真正期待的是连接。而这正是我认为造就了我所做的事情与众不同的地方。那种感觉毫无矫揉造作。但你开创了太多的“第一次”。我记得有几件事让我记忆犹新。
I remember hearing before I listened to hearing that you got Obama on was really huge. I remember everybody was freaking out about like, that was the first time somebody had done something like that gotten a president to come on the thing. And then you did the live shows too, of which I did one of them actually in Brooklyn at the bell as well.
我记得在听之前听说你请到了奥巴马，那真的是一件大事。我记得所有人都疯狂了，那是第一次有人做到那种事，让一位总统来上节目。然后你还做了现场演出，其中有一场我其实在布鲁克林的贝尔音乐厅（The Bell House）也参加过。
And in addition to the going to your house and that was like, I was like, I remember you getting the call saying like, Mark's doing this thing at the bell is live in the pie. I was like, what could that getting the call saying like, Mark's doing this thing at the Bell and it's live in the pie, I was like, what could that be? Well, it was different. Yeah, it was different, it was cool. I was like, oh, okay. But the reason for that really was,
除了去你家做节目，我记得当时我接到电话说“马克要在贝尔音乐厅做现场播客秀”时，我当时就在想，那会是什么情况？接到电话说“马克要在贝尔音乐厅做现场播客秀”，我当时就在想，那会是什么情况？好吧，这很不同。是的，很不同，也很酷。我当时想，哦，好吧。但其实原因在于，
Obama was later, but the live ones, there was no way to make money doing this at the beginning. There was literally no way. I mean, advertisers weren't forthcoming. We were using kind of old terrestrial radio middlemen to get like sex toy ads and audible. Yeah, our first ads were like Adam and Eve. You know, you'd get a free package of God knows what.
奥巴马是后来的事了，但关于现场演出，在最开始的时候，做这个根本赚不到钱。字面意义上完全赚不到。我的意思是，广告商并不积极。我们当时使用的是那种老旧的传统电台中间商，去拉一些情趣玩具广告和Audible（有声书）广告。是的，我们的第一批广告就像亚当和夏娃（成人用品）。你知道的，你会免费得到一包天知道是什么的东西。
We had this other advertiser from an older show we did, Just Coffee, but there was no way to generate income. And unless you wanted to sort of do a, you know, pay to listen kind of thing, but then you wouldn't build an audience. So the live shows were things we did separately and we created a different website so people would pay for them.
我们还有另一个来自我们以前做过的一个老节目的广告商，Just Coffee，但根本没有办法产生收入。除非你想搞那种付费收听之类的东西，但那样你就无法建立听众群。所以现场演出是我们分开来做的事情，我们创建了一个不同的网站，这样人们就会为之付费。
There's no way to make money. So the live shows were kind of an income generating thing. I mean, at the beginning of this thing, in my old house, we were just doing a tiered donation thing. This was before, you know, WhatsApp platform where everyone, you know, WhatsApp platform where everyone, you know, you get paid on. GoFundMe or something?
根本赚不到钱。所以现场演出算是一种创收的手段。我的意思是，在这个东西刚开始的时候，在我以前的家里，我们只是在搞分级捐赠。这还在，你知道的，那种每个人都会给钱的WhatsApp平台之前。GoFundMe或者别的什么？
Yeah, it was not GoFundMe, the other one where you have a site where people can pay, whatever. Everyone has it. Patreon, OnlyFans? Yeah, Patreon. So there was no Patreon. So at the beginning, we just offered tiered donations and you gave a certain amount of money,
对，不是GoFundMe，是另一个你可以让人付款的网站，随便吧。大家都有这个。Patreon，OnlyFans？对，Patreon。所以当时还没有Patreon。所以在刚开始的时候，我们只是提供分级捐赠，如果你捐了特定金额的钱，
I'd send you a T-shirt and some stickers and my house was filled with a thousand envelopes, you know, stuff and T-shirts, because there's no way to make money. So the life ones were gone. I remember your assistant there working at a table just fucking stuffing envelopes. Yeah, yeah, that's right.
我就会寄给你一件T恤和一些贴纸，然后我的家里塞满了上千个信封，你知道的，装着各种东西和T恤，因为根本赚不到钱。所以现场活动就这么没了。我还记得你当时的助手在那张桌子旁疯狂地装信封。对，对，没错。
That's right. It was crazy. But the Obama thing, that was a whole other thing. But I think in terms of the medium, that kind of put it on the map. It kind of validated. And how did that come about? Yeah, validated, legitimized it.
没错。太疯狂了。但奥巴马那件事，那是完全不同的另一码事。不过我认为就这个媒介而言，那件事把它真正推上了地图。它起到了验证和合法化的作用。
And that was a result of your numbers being such that his team took notice of you and suggested, recommended to him that this might be a good spot for him to hit? I don't know if it was numbers per se, as much as it was profile, and I think that really it came down to then that there was a fan in the OVO office.
那是由于你的节目数据太好，以至于他的团队注意到了你，并向他建议，这可能是他光顾的一个好地方？我不知道是不是因为数据本身，更多是因为知名度，而且我觉得归根结底是因为椭圆形办公室里有一个粉丝。
I mean, an intern, I don't know who it was. Got it, right. But they thought it would be good. It was his last year, second term. Yeah. He didn't want to be a lame duck, I don't think, and he thought it would be, or someone in his world thought it would be a good look to
我的意思是，一个实习生，我不知道是谁。明白了，对。但他们觉得这会是个好主意。那是他的最后一年，第二任期。是的，我猜他不想当跛脚鸭，他觉得这会——或者他世界里的某个人觉得这是一个很好的形象，
to kind of do this and I remember when my producer Brendan McDonald was like Obama wants to come on and I'm like so what I'm going to I'm going to the White House and he said no He's coming to Highland Park. I'm like that's fucking crazy Walk us through that product I always wanted to know that like this because we had the opportunity of doing it with Biden. But what was that like, but we went to him and we went through all the protocols and stuff. What was that like, them coming to your neighborhood,
可以做这种事。我记得我的制作人布伦丹·麦克唐纳（Brendan McDonald）说奥巴马想来的时候，我说，什么，我要去白宫吗？他说，不，他要来海地公园（Highland Park）。我说，这太疯狂了。给我们讲讲那个制作过程吧，我一直想知道这个，因为我们有机会和拜登做过节目。那是什么感觉，但我们去找了他，经历了一系列协议什么的。那是什么感觉，他们带着总统来到你的社区，来到你的家里？
to your house with the president? Completely unsecured. It was crazy. Well, at first, I had a trip planned and I rarely take vacations, so I told my producer, I'm like, I don't know, I'm supposed to go to Hawaii. He goes, no, you're not going anywhere. So, well, the thing was, the first things we had to think
完全没有戒严保护。太疯狂了。好吧，一开始，我计划了一次旅行，我很少休假，所以我告诉我的制作人，我说，我不知道，我本该去夏威夷的。他说，不，你哪儿也去不了。所以，好吧，当时的情况是，我们首先要考虑的是
about was the way we do the show, which is not a political show. I mean, I can do that, but we had, both of us had come out of Air America, and from the beginning of the podcast, we were like, we're not doing a political show because I don't want to carry that water. You can't really do politics with your own voice
我们做节目的方式，这不是一个政治节目。我的意思是，我能做那个，但我们俩都曾从“美国之音”电台（Air America）出来，从播客一开始，我们就说过，我们不做政治节目，因为我不想去趟那浑水。你不能真正用你自己的声音去搞政治，
because you'll eventually end up just carrying whatever load it is of talking points for whatever party you're affiliated with. But the thing was is we got to make it a personal interview. He did go to college down the street at least for a couple of years. He knows the neighborhood. And we had to really structure it more than we do that.
因为你最终只会沦为某个你所属政党的政治谈话要点的传声筒。但关键在于，我们得把它做成一次个人访谈。他至少在街那头的大学上过几年学。他了解这个社区。而且我们必须对它进行结构化处理，这比我们平时做的要多。
Wait, which college did he go to around Highland Park? Yeah, at Occidental. Oh, right. So, you know, we had a school. Oh, so not on purpose. No, we had to structure it in a way. That was for Sean, that was for Sean. Occidental. Sean loves that.
等等，他在海地公园附近上的是哪所大学？对，在西方学院（Occidental）。哦，对。所以，你知道的，我们有一所学校。哦，所以不是故意的。不，我们必须以某种方式构建它。那是对肖恩说的，那是对肖恩说的。西方学院。肖恩最喜欢这个了。
Sorry, sorry Mark. Low hanging fruit is still fruit for me, I'm so sorry. Okay. Throw the baby some candy every once in a while. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. So they what, they come two weeks before and they strip search you every hour?
抱歉，抱歉，马克。唾手可得的笑料对我来说依然是笑料，非常抱歉。好吧。偶尔给这孩子一点甜头。我们马上回来。现在回到节目中。所以他们怎么着，提前两周来，然后每小时对你进行一次脱衣搜身？
Well here's what happens, so I end up going to Hawaii and reading his book and in the meantime, Brendan, who is in Brooklyn generally, flew out to meet the Secret Service to create a perimeter. And so you get all these Secret Service guys at the house and apparently, Brendan was in the garage and he had a couple of guys on the roof jumping on it to figure out whether they could post guys up there.
事情是这样的，我最后去了夏威夷，读了他的书。与此同时，通常在布鲁克林的布伦丹飞出来与特勤局会面，以划定一个周界。于是你家里就来了一群特勤局特工，显然，布伦丹当时在车库里，他还让几个家伙跳到屋顶上来回踩，以测试他们能不能把人安排在那上面。
And Brendan was like, no, no, it's coming down. So I had to ask my retired neighbor if we could put snipers on his roof, and it was like the greatest thing that ever happened to him. He was thrilled to be involved. But the sort of the day of, the one thing that was scary is they put some sort of weird humming black box in the one spare bedroom.
而布伦丹则说，不，不，这房顶要塌了。所以我不得不问我退休的邻居，我们能不能把狙击手安排在他的屋顶上，这对那家伙来说简直是这辈子发生过的最棒的事。他兴奋极了，能参与其中。但到了当天的情形，有一点很吓人，他们在其中一个客房里放了一个某种奇怪的、发出嗡嗡声的黑色盒子。
That was a small house, if you remember. It was like less than a thousand square feet with one toilet. I remember the black box too. Guys, remember when we tried to put our coffee on it? I don't remember. And they said don't touch that thing. Why, why, what is it?
如果你还记得的话，那是间很小的房子。面积不到一千平方公里——不，平方英尺，只有一个马桶。我也记得那个黑色盒子。伙计们，还记得我们当时试图把咖啡放在上面吗？我不记得了。他们说别碰那东西。为什么，为什么，那是什么？
Ken and Rob remember. When we were at the- What is it? What it is, it's like if all communications break down, that thing has a line into some sort of, you know, a secret satellite network, right. Oh, I see, wow. So they gotta put that in, and that was kind of the most menacing thing.
肯和罗布记得。当我们呆在——那是什么？那东西的作用是，如果所有的通讯都中断了，那个东西有一条专线连接到某种，你知道的，秘密卫星网络。哦，原来如此，哇。所以他们必须把那个放进去，那可以说是最具有威胁性的东西了。
And I remember like the day of, wow, so the day of there was like at least 15, Secret Service people and then we'd set up tables on the deck there. My biggest fear was that that house had one toilet and I'm like, where's he gonna go to the bath? What if someone needs to go to the bathroom? I gotta clean the bath, whatever.
我还记得当天的情景，哇，所以当天现场至少有15名特勤局人员，我们在那里的露台上摆了桌子。我最大的恐惧是那栋房子只有一个马桶，当时我想，他要去哪儿上厕所？如果有人需要上厕所怎么办？我得把浴室打扫干净，诸如此类的。
So we set up a table with listening stations for the White House people, for Brendan, for whoever else needed them. So there was like four or five sets of headphones out there. And the amazing thing about Obama, that there was no pre-interview. We didn't have to get any approval of any questions. He was completely confident and lucid.
所以我们摆了一张桌子，上面放着给白宫人员、布伦丹以及其他任何需要的人使用的监听设备。所以那里大概有四五副耳机。而关于奥巴马最神奇的一点是，根本没有会前采访。我们不需要获得任何问题的批准。他完全自信而清晰。
And he knew what he was getting into. But the funny thing was, is that the Secret Service is coming in with the dogs, and I got these cats, and I'm like, hey, is there any way he can skip the house? I got cats, I'm gonna put them in the bedroom, but you trust me enough to leave the cats in the bedroom? Now, well, they said yes, and they let me off the hook,
而且他清楚自己将要面对的是什么。但有趣的是，特勤局带着狗进来了，而我养了猫，当时我就想，嘿，有什么办法能让他别进屋吗？我有猫，我会把它们关在卧室里，但你们能信任我把猫留在卧室里吗？现在，好吧，他们说可以，他们放了我一马，
but I don't know if that's gonna get them in trouble, but I think they're probably out of the game anyways. But anyway, so we're waiting now. We're all in a waiting position. My producer, he wore a sports jacket. He's very proper. Good for him. Yeah, and all the secret services there,
但我不知道这会不会给他们惹麻烦，不过我想他们大概无论如何也已经退役了。不管怎样，所以我们现在在等待。我们都处于待命状态。我的制作人穿了一件运动夹克。他非常得体。这很好。是的，所有的特勤局人员都在那儿，
and I'm waiting on outside. And I say, how are we gonna know they're coming? And we'll give you a heads up when he's 20 minutes out. So what he was doing, he was flying from Beverly Hills in the Air Force Two or whatever, the helicopter, to the Rose Bowl to park there, which is about 10 minutes from my house. So they're like, well, that's better than, you know,
而我在外面等着。我说，我们怎么知道他们什么时候来？他们会在他离这儿20分钟的时候通知我们。他当时在做什么呢，他正坐空军二号或者别的什么直升机从比弗利山庄飞到玫瑰碗球场停在那里，离我家大约有10分钟路程。所以他们觉得，嗯，这总比，你知道的，
stopping traffic in the entire fucking city of LA. So they said- To go to Mark's garage. Yeah, yeah, exactly. They cleared the street of all cars. Some neighbors were pissed a couple. Sure. The Republicans were pissed, but the rational people
堵塞整个洛杉矶该死的城市的交通要好。所以他们说——去马克车库。对，对，正好。他们清理了街上的所有汽车。有些邻居气坏了。当然。共和党人很生气，但理性的人
were like, this is great. They're gonna line the streets. So they said 20 minutes out, we'll tell you. But then all of a sudden we see the helicopters, two Ospreys that kind of fly in front of the helicopter. And we could see him in the sky. I'm like, all right, well, he's close. I'm just waiting at the gate and the motorcade pulls up
则觉得这太棒了。他们会列队夹道欢迎。所以他们说20分钟到，会通知我们。但突然之间我们看到了直升机，两架“鱼鹰”直升机在直升机前面飞行。我们能在空中看到他。我想，好吧，他快到了。我正等在大门口，车队就开过来了，
and there's this flurry of people coming up my driveway. I don't even see Obama. And then I see him and he's in the middle of this crowd. He waves like, Mark, and I'm like, Mr. President. He walks up and he's like, are we gonna have a good time? I'm like, I don't know. But then we go into the garage, they only had one Secret Service guy at the door behind me.
一大群人涌上我的车道。我甚至都没看到奥巴马。然后我看到了他，他正处在人群中间。他挥着手说，马克，我说，总统先生。他走过来问，我们能过得很愉快吗？我说，我不知道。但随后我们走进车库，门后只有一个特勤局特工。
They had some sort of flak mat. That was another weird item that they actually left and I had to get back to them. That kind of like, if there's an attack or something, it kind of pops up and protects him. But it was all, it was intense. And I just tried to, we had to cover some politics upfront because there were things unfolding. But then it was a fairly standard WTF interview.
他们有一种防弹垫。那是另一个奇怪的物品，他们实际上落下了，我不得不把它还给他们。那种东西，如果发生袭击什么的，它会弹起来保护他。但这一切，非常紧张。我只是试着——我们一开始必须聊一些政治，因为当时局势正在发展。但那之后，这是一场相当标准的WTF访谈。
And the funniest part about it was when he sat down, I said, so you're nervous? And he said something like, if I was nervous about this, we'd all be in trouble. Yeah. He was pretty forthcoming though, yeah? Yeah. Yeah, forthcoming enough.
最搞笑的是，当他坐下来时，我说，那你很紧张吗？他说了一句类似的话：如果我对这个感到紧张，我们所有人都有麻烦了。是啊。不过他挺坦率的，对吧？对。对，还算挺坦率。
He's a genuine person. What he was was very disarming and very candid seeming and willing and thoughtful. But what's interesting is that it was better to do a personal interview with him because he is kind of wonky. And if you get into politics, it can get a little long. And we only had an hour.
他是一个真诚的人。他表现出来的是非常平易近人，看起来非常坦诚、乐意配合且善解人意。但有趣的是，对他的个人采访效果更好，因为他有点书呆子气。如果你深入探讨政治，可能会变得有点冗长。而我们只有一个小时。
So we were able to kind of do it. And then for some reason he chose, I'm sure very deliberately to say the N word on my show. And that- Really? And that, yeah. In relation to, he was like, racism isn't over just because he can't say the N word and he said it.
所以我们基本上做到了。然后出于某种原因，我确信他是非常刻意地在我的节目中说出了那个N开头的词。而那——真的吗？而那个，是的。关于，他当时的意思是，种族主义并没有因为他不能说那个N开头的词而结束，然后他就说出来了。
So that got, you know, a flurry of international news. So I had to deal with, you know, news crews in front of my house. But my- Yeah, there aren't enough T-shirts and stickers to handle that. Yeah. No.
所以这引发了，你知道的，一阵国际新闻狂潮。因此我不得不应付，你知道的，我家门前的新闻记者。不过我——是的，T恤和贴纸根本不够应付那场面。对。没错。
But my producer was very calculating in terms of the press we did. He's a very smart guy. We, you know, we didn't engage with any of them. We just did, we did Chris Hayes and we did Terry Gross and that was it. And I don't hear from Obama at all. He's got my number, but I feel weird texting him.
但我的制作人在我们做的媒体公关方面非常有心计。他是个非常聪明的人。我们，你知道的，我们没有理会他们中的任何一个。我们就只上了克里斯·海斯的节目，上了特里·格罗斯的节目，就这样了。而且我完全没有奥巴马的消息。他有我的号码，但我发短信觉得怪怪的。
But you know, I mean, look, the fact that you, A, were able to book him says a lot about the spirit and the content of your show. But your ability to get him to do a personal interview and to get him to be forthcoming really speaks to sort of I think what makes you so great at what you do. And are you comfortable trying to maybe kind of speak to that and maybe dissect that a little bit? Because you know, this one hour conversation, hour conversation, there needed to be at some point a confidence from you
但你知道的，我的意思是，听着，你能预约到他，A，这本身就说明了你的节目精神和内容很有分量。但你能让他接受个人采访并让他畅所欲言，这真的很能说明，我认为正是这些造就了你现在的出色。你是否愿意试着谈谈这一点，并稍微剖析一下？因为你知道的，这一个小时的对话，一个小时的对话，在某个时刻需要你有一种自信
about me just freestyling and then having somebody sit down and me just kind of pop back and forth with them and have a conversation as opposed to being an investigative journalist needs to be compelling and I need to assume that that's gonna be entertaining. What made you think that your hot takes on things and your personal kind of, the way in which you can drive a conversation
关于我只是即兴发挥，然后有人坐下来，我和他们一来一回地交流，进行对话，而不是作为一个需要引人入胜的调查记者，而且我需要假设那会是有趣的。是什么让你觉得你对事物的热烈评论以及你个人的那种、你推动对话的方式
would be something really compelling? Because it is. And you are. Yeah, what gave you the right to think you could do this, Mark? But like, when did that happen for you? Just because I know you've spoken in the past about whatever the right words would be about
会是非常引人入胜的？因为事实确实如此。而你也确实很棒。是的，马克，是什么给了你权利让你觉得你能做到这一点？但是，这种转变是什么时候发生的？只是因为我知道你过去曾谈论过，不管用什么词来形容
your degrees of social comfort and what fuels your standup and your cynicism and stuff, which I share with you. Like a lot of that doesn't lend itself to being a conversationalist. Do you know what I mean? Well, I think how it evolved is that I am innately and almost immediately codependent with any personality that sits in front of me.
你的社交舒适度，以及是什么在支撑着你的单口喜剧和你的玩世不恭之类的东西，这些我都和你一样。就像其中很多并不适合成为一个擅长对话的人。你知道我的意思吗？嗯，我认为它的演变过程是，我天生并且几乎立刻就会与坐在我面前的任何个性产生共生关系。
So it's just by virtue of my upbringing, I don't know what. But there was a, the way it sort of started, and this is one of the reasons why we're winding it down, is that I'm kind of all in no matter what I do. My standup is provocative and personal, and sometimes a little cringy, and just my basic demeanor in terms of what I wanna talk about and what I feel comfortable talking about,
所以这纯粹是出于我的成长经历，我不知道是什么。但有一种，它开始的方式，这也是我们现在要结束它的原因之一，那就是无论我做什么，我都是全力以赴的。我的单口喜剧具有挑衅性且非常私人，有时甚至有点令人尴尬，就我想谈论的内容以及我对谈论什么感到自在而言，我的基本态度，
and my need to connect with people is sort of ingrained in me, and I'm willing to volunteer a lot of myself. And I think that the conversations that, in the beginning, I was literally having comedians over to apologize to them. So I, you know, for being a dick or whatever I thought my issues were or whether they were mad at me.
以及我与人连接的需求已经深深植根于我，我愿意展现很大一部分自我。我认为这些对话，在刚开始时，我真的是请喜剧演员来向他们道歉。所以，你知道的，因为我曾是个混蛋，或者无论我认为自己的问题是什么，或者他们是否生我的气。
So the style unfolded with me trying to get resolution and make amends and this and that. And also I think the way I characterize it is generally the first 100 episodes were me having celebrities over to talk about my problems. So, and that became a way, you know, it's very disarming when you offer yourself. When you pull your pants down,
所以这种风格就在我试图解决问题、弥补过失的过程中逐渐形成了。而且我认为我的概括是，通常前100集都是我请名人来谈论我的问题。所以，这就成了一种方式，你知道的，当你敞开心扉时，这是非常卸下防备的。当你脱下裤子，
it's everybody feels kind of safe and like, okay, so I guess we're gonna be honest. I love that. Yeah. Oh, when you pull your pants down, it's everybody feels kind of safe and like, okay, so I guess we're gonna be honest. I love that. Yeah. Oh, when you pull your pants down, everybody feels safe. Yeah. Yeah. And confident, yeah.
每个人都会觉得有点安全感，然后就会想，好吧，我想我们要坦诚相见了。我喜欢这个。对。哦，当你脱下裤子，每个人都会觉得安全感。对。对。而且充满信心，对。
But so that's how it sort of evolved and it's a need for me because I don't, like my preparation is just getting a broad view of who people are, what they've done. And it's evolved over time in terms of how I handle certain interviews. If somebody has an amazing, if it's an older person with a large bulk of work,
但这就是它演变的方式，这是我的需求，因为我不需要，就像我的准备工作只是对人们是谁、他们做过什么有一个广泛的了解。随着时间的推移，我在处理某些采访时的方式也发生了演变。如果有人拥有惊人的成就，如果是一个有着大量作品的老年人，
I'll forego the really personal stuff to really talk about the work, but it all gets mixed in. Well, let me ask you, has it changed the way you, I'll ask all of you guys, and I don't know if I have an answer. You can say all y'all. All y'all.
我会放弃那些非常私人的东西，真正去谈论作品，但这些都融合在一起。好吧，让我问你，这改变了你的方式吗，我要问你们所有人，我不知道我有没有答案。你可以说“你们所有人”。你们所有人。
Has it changed, I'll speak for myself first. I think that doing this over the last five years, which is just kind of odd to me. Right, but think about that. We've only done 300 episodes. He's done 1600. No, I know, I know. It's amazing. It's amazing. odd to me. Right, but think about that. We've only done 300 episodes. He's done 1600. No, I know, I know. It's amazing.
这改变了吗，我先为自己说话。我认为在过去的五年里做这件事，这对我来说有点奇怪。对，但想想看。我们只做了300集。他做了1600集。不，我知道，我知道。这太惊人了。这太惊人了。
It's amazing. But for sure. So, but for us, for the last five years, certainly for me, I can only speak for myself, that it has changed a little bit the way that I talk to people. I don't just mean people out in the world, like, hey, I'm a fan.
太惊人了。但肯定的。所以，但对我们来说，在过去的五年里，对我和我来说，我只能代表我自己，这确实稍微改变了我与人交谈的方式。我不仅仅是指世界上的那些人，比如，嘿，我是个粉丝。
I mean just like people in general. It has, this has shaped a little bit how I interact with people, to a certain degree. It's not the driving, but it has become a big part of who I am now having these conversations and talking in this way, for whatever reason, for better or for worse. Well, it's interesting because you guys are all actors
我是指一般意义上的人。这确实，无论出于什么原因，无论是好是坏，这在一定程度上塑造了我和人交往的方式，在某种程度上。这不是驱动力，但这已经成为我现在的很大一部分，通过进行这些对话和以这种方式交谈。好吧，这很有趣，因为你们都是演员
and part of that craft from what I understand, about 90% of it is being present and listening. So whether you were used to doing that in your real life or not, who knows, but I mean, it is a tool that you all have to be present and listen. That's applicable to this. Yeah, and it's a real thing that you know
据我所了解，这种手艺的一部分，大约90%就是活在当下并学会倾听。所以不管你是否习惯在现实生活中这样做，谁知道呢，但我的意思是，这是你们所有人必须具备的活在当下并倾听的工具。这适用于此。是的，这是一件真实的事情，你知道
because we're all kind of self-centered guys and you know you kind of you want to get your word in you want to you know you're kind of half listening but once you start to engage your your empathy and your ability to shut the fuck up you find that you it is the foundation of connection yeah yeah and and I think that does change I think that I'm a- I'm so afraid to talk now. Keep going. No, you go.
因为我们都是那种以自我为中心的人，你知道你总是想插话，你想，你知道的，你其实只听了一半，但一旦你开始调动你的同理心和闭上你他妈的嘴的能力，你就会发现，这是建立连接的基础。对，对，而且我认为这确实改变了，我觉得我——我现在太害怕说话了。继续。不，你来。
No, no. I'm kidding, I'm kidding. No, you go. But for me, it took a lot to do that. And some people still are sort of like, why don't you let the guests talk? And I'm like, because it's my show. So-
不，不。我开玩笑的，我开玩笑的。不，你来。但对我来说，做到这一点花了很多精力。有些人仍然会觉得，你为什么不让嘉宾说话？而我的回答是：因为这是我的节目。所以——
Yeah. Exactly. And also, over years, you kind of, you know when someone's going into a public narrative. And some of those are deeper than you can imagine. There's ways that public people talk that, there's sometimes I know like,
是的。没错。而且，多年来，你逐渐地，你知道当某人开始进入公开的叙事时。其中有些比你能想象的还要深。公众说话的方式有那么几种，有时候我知道，
well, I know this story has been told, God knows how many times, but maybe my listeners, I haven't heard it, but if it's something that I'm like, well, he's, or she's kind of autopiloting here, I'll interrupt until I can get them off of that and get them into some other place. Did you ever get that thing? Well, first of all, did you ever read comments
嗯，我知道这个故事已经被讲过，天知道有多少次了，但也许我的听众们，还没听过，但如果是一件我觉得，好吧，他，或者她在自动驾驶的状态下讲述，我会打断他，直到我能让他们脱离那种状态，带他们进入其他地方。你有没有遇到过这种情况？首先，当你在社交媒体上发布内容，比如宣传节目时，你会看评论吗？
when you put stuff out on social, like to promote the show? I try not to, you know, but you know, it's kind of addicting. I don't check the numbers. I don't know what the, when Twitter was a viable thing, I would look at those and that would be upsetting. And it took me years to learn not to engage.
我尽量不看，你知道的，但这有点让人上瘾。我不看数据。我不知道当Twitter还是一个可行的平台时，我会去看那些评论，那会让人沮丧。我花了多年时间才学会不去参与。
I have an email. I used to follow you on Twitter and you would sometimes engage and I would see the stuff that you would say. It's a nightmare. Yeah, it's a nightmare. But would it change, would it alter the way, cause I remember, I haven't looked in forever.
我有一个电子邮件。我以前在Twitter上关注你，你有时会参与其中，我会看到你说的那些话。那简直是个噩梦。是的，是个噩梦。但这会改变，会改变你的方式吗，因为我记得，我已经好久没看过了。
Yeah, it expanded my self-consciousness, which is just what you need. Yeah, exactly. You take in just random bullshit trolling and you're like, that guy kind of nailed it. I got to be aware of that. Yeah, well we used to have that, exactly. And I used to have that early days,
是的，它放大了我的自我意识，这正是你所需要的。是的，完全正确。你接受那些随机的废话喷子，然后你会想：那家伙说得还真有点道理。我得注意这一点。是的，好吧，我们以前也有过，完全是这样。我早期也有过，
it would be a lot, and people I'm sure still do it. They're like, I wish Arnett would shut the fuck up. Why is he talking, why is he interrupting? And I'm like, by the way, turn it off. Yeah, turn it off. And it's your show. As opposed to like, you know, honor Hawkwin Two's comments about you.
会有很多，而且我确信现在人们还在这样做。他们会说：我希望阿内特能闭上他妈的嘴。他为什么在说话，他为什么老是打断？而我说，顺便说一句，关掉它。是的，关掉它。这是你的节目。而不是像，你知道的，尊重霍克温·图关于你的评论。
Yeah. You know? Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Some guy with four followers in the UK, you're like, oh, Jesus, I gotta reassess my whole life with some idiot sitting at a computer.
是吗？你知道的？对，对。对，对。对，对。英国有四个粉丝的某个家伙，你就会想：哦，天哪，我得和一个坐在电脑前的白痴重新评估我的整个人生。
Because there is a sense for some reason, no matter how old you are, we're older, but you see one comment on a social media platform, and some part of your brain goes, the entire internet thinks I suck. And it's like, one idiot. But still, if it's a bad morning, you gotta fight the urge.
因为某种原因，无论你多大年纪，我们年纪都大了，但你在社交媒体平台上看到一条评论，你大脑的一部分就会想：整个互联网都觉得我很逊。这就像是一个白痴。但尽管如此，如果是一个糟糕的早晨，你必须克制这种冲动。
So Mark, so when you started WTF, you'd obviously had, I used to listen to you on Air America all the time, and you'd done a bunch of other things. What made you, take us back to what the landscape was for the medium of podcasting. Like, what made you think that there was even money there?
所以，马克，当你开始做WTF时，你显然已经，我以前经常在美利坚之音听你的节目，你还做过很多其他事情。是什么让你，把我们带回当时播客媒介的生态环境。就像，是什么让你觉得那里甚至有钱可赚？
That there was an avenue there? What was, you know? I'm not a money guy. For better or for worse, I ended up with some, but it's never been my driving motivation. My motivation with comedy and with this has always been like, I want to be seen and heard because I don't know who I am.
觉得那里有一条出路？是什么，你知道的？我不是一个爱钱的人。不管好坏，我最终确实赚到了一些，但这从来不是我的动力。我和喜剧以及这个节目的动力一直都是：我想被看到和听到，因为我不知道我是谁。
Yeah. So, I am building a sense of self here and I want you all to be involved. But at the beginning, we had, Brendan and I, Air America collapsed and you know, and we, you know, I got pushed out, you know, to LA and I did an evening show that no one listened to for a while but then it just went away.
是的。所以，我在这里建立一种自我意识，而我希望你们所有人都参与进来。但在刚开始时，我们有，布伦丹和我，美利坚之音倒闭了，你知道的，然后我们，你知道的，我被挤压到了洛杉矶，我做了一个晚间节目，有一段时间没人听，但后来它就消失了。
And, you know, like at the same time, I was going through kind of a miserable divorce and there was an outreach from Air America, they're like, we wanna pull you back in to do a streaming show. And this is before streaming, this is like 2007, no one knew what streaming was. So I'm like, fine, and I said,
而且，你知道，与此同时，我正经历一场痛苦的离婚，美利坚之音向我伸出了橄榄枝，他们说：我们想把你拉回来做一个流媒体节目。这是在流媒体出现之前，大概是2007年，当时没人知道流媒体是什么。所以我说，好吧，我说，
can you give me this amount of money so I can pay her off, so I can get my life back? So they gave me this money to pay her off, and then they gave me this job at Air America doing a streaming show with Sam Cedar that no one could really watch. And so, love Sam Cedar. Yeah, yeah, and so.
你能给我这么多钱让我把她打发走，好让我找回生活吗？于是他们给了我这笔钱把她打发走，然后给了我在美利坚之音的工作，和山姆·塞德尔一起做一个没人能真正看到的流媒体节目。所以，我爱山姆·塞德尔。是的，是的，所以。
I haven't seen him in so long anyways. So it was me and Cedar doing this show that crapped out in a year, and we knew it would, and I was like devastated and heartbroken so I was kind of useless. But we were at the studios at Air America, that version of it, which was a very kind of broken down version. And once our contract was up, they fired us
我好久没见到他了。所以我和塞德尔一起做这个节目，一年后就泡汤了，我们早就知道会这样，我当时崩溃且心碎，所以我整个人基本上废了。但我们在美利坚之音的录音室里，那个版本的录音室，是一个非常破败的版本。一旦我们的合同到期，他们就解雇了我们
but we still had like two months on the contract and being good liberals, they're like, well you guys can use the offices, which is unheard of when you do a radio job. They usually don't let him near the mics, give him his take away his card and get him out. But they didn't. Didn't Cheney Garofalo have a show on Air America as well? Not then. No, that was the original one. But this was like, this was when they had like
但我们的合同其实还有大约两个月，作为优秀的自由主义者，他们说：好吧，你们可以使用办公室。这在做电台工作时是闻所未闻的。他们通常不让你靠近麦克风，收回你的卡然后把你赶出去。但他们没有。钱尼·加罗法洛不是也在美利坚之音有自己的节目吗？那时没有。不，那是最初的那个。但这就像是，这是他们拥有像
Montell Williams and it was a and who's that other guy? Lionel, that weirdo. So and we were just in this office doing a streaming show. And so we're out of a job. And I said to Brendan, my producer, I said, look man, there are these podcasts, there's a few of them. Corolla had moved his radio show into the podcast form, but it was really just a radio show. I think who was around, Jimmy Pardo.
蒙特尔·威廉姆斯的时候，那是一个，还有那个另一个家伙是谁？莱昂内尔，那个怪咖。所以我们只是在这个办公室里做一个流媒体节目。然后我们失业了。我对我的制作人布伦丹说，我说，听着，老兄，有这些播客，有那么几个。科罗拉把他的电台节目搬到了播客形式，但这其实只是个电台节目。我想当时还有谁，吉米·帕多。
Ricky was doing one like, Gervais was like every once in a while kind of thing. Yeah, yeah, he was around, but there was only about five that had any profile, really five or six, it was pre-Rogan. And it came, and you could only find it on the Apple iPod itself, which is where it gets its name, podcasting, right?
瑞奇当时也在做，比如热维斯偶尔会做那种。对，对，他当时也在，但真正有知名度的也就大约五个，实际上是五个或六个，那是罗根之前的事。而且，你只能在苹果iPod本身上找到它，这也是它名字的由来，播客（podcasting），对吧？
Well, that's what they, that's the thing is that, you know, Apple at that time, I said to Brendan, I didn't know that either. Can you figure out how to do this? And maybe we should do it. And at that time, I said to Brendan, I didn't know that either. Can you figure out how to do this and maybe we should do it? And at that time, Apple just wanted anybody with a name to do them and they'd get behind you because it's not a platform as much as it is just,
嗯，这就是他们，这就是那回事，你知道的，苹果当时，我对布伦丹说，我当时也不知道这个。你能弄清楚怎么做这个吗？也许我们应该做这个。而在那个时候，我对布伦丹说，我也不会这个。你能弄清楚怎么做这个，也许我们应该做这个？而在那个时候，苹果只是希望任何有点名气的人来做，他们会支持你，因为这与其说是一个平台，不如说它只是，
you know, like it's not a server. It was also, it was part of the thing to like actually sell the hardware, the iPod itself. You could only get it on this new device that they were learning. That's right. Wow. So they kind of got behind us and we were kind of going. That's the first thing I've ever learned from Jason.
你知道的，就像它不是一个服务器。这也是为了实际销售硬件，也就是iPod本身的一部分。你只能在这个他们正在了解的新设备上获取它。没错了。哇。所以他们算是支持了我们，然后我们就这样开始运作了。这是我从杰森那里学到的第一件事。
Yeah, enjoy. Wow. It's all about that, dude. Same with Apple TV. You know, it's like, that's just about getting people to get Apple TV. Buy hardware, yeah. Wow.
是的，好好享受吧。哇。老兄，这全都是为了那个。苹果电视也是一样。你知道的，这其实就是为了让人去买苹果电视。购买硬件，对吧。哇。
So we started kind of going in after hours, we had cards, we knew the night tech, and we were bringing guests up the freight elevator, and it wasn't really the same show at the beginning, but it was all just sort of, I needed to keep doing something. I thought my comedy career was nowhere. I certainly wasn't acting,
所以我们开始在非工作时间去那里，我们有门卡，我们认识夜班技术员，我们带着嘉宾坐货梯上去，一开始这并不是真正的同一个节目，但这其实都只是，我需要继续做点什么。我当时觉得我的喜剧生涯毫无希望，我肯定没有在演戏，
and I didn't know what to do with my life, so it was kind of a Hail Mary, but there was no way to make money. It must have been scary. Was it a scary time, or were you kind of comfortable Hail Mary, but there was no way to make money. It must have been scary. Was it a scary time or were you kind of comfortable with your set in life? Well, I knew that for whatever reason, I was good on these mics,
我不知道该拿我的人生怎么办，所以这有点像死马当活马医，但当时根本没有赚钱的途径。那一定很可怕。那是一个可怕的时期，还是你对死马当活马医的现状感到比较习惯，但当时根本没有赚钱的途径。那一定很可怕。那是一个可怕的时期，还是你对自己的生活状态感到比较习惯？好吧，我知道无论出于什么原因，我在这些麦克风前表现得很好，
because I knew that, and Brendan knew that as well. That there was a way, who knows why anyone's gonna be good on these. But there was a way I kind of approached it that was very sort of immediate and honest and sort of searching. Did it feel like your last shot, I guess is my question. Yeah, I mean, like I used to make a joke about it
因为我知道这一点，布伦丹也很清楚这一点。一定有某种方法，谁知道为什么有人会在这些上面表现好呢。但我处理它的方式非常直接、诚实且具有探索性。我猜我的问题是，这感觉像是你的最后一次机会吗？是的，我的意思是，我以前经常拿这个开玩笑
that I, you know, when I moved out to LA and I set the mics up in the garage, I was like, this is the same garage I thought about killing myself in. Yeah. But I had no expectations. There was no money expectation. It was just me trying to do something.
那就是我，你知道，当我搬到洛杉矶并在车库里架起麦克风时，我想过：这就是我曾想过要在里面自杀的同一个车库。是的。但我没有任何期望。没有任何金钱上的期望。这只是我试图做点事情。
And then, through weird timing and just trying to focus on building a social media presence, getting people who have that on the show. And then because the celebrity press had become kind of anemic, people were locking in because I was doing their job for them. So Vulture was there. What was the moment?
然后，通过奇怪的时机以及专注于建立社交媒体的存在感，把那些拥有社交媒体影响力的人请到节目中。后来，因为名流新闻变得有点乏力，人们开始锁定收听，因为我是在替他们干活。所以Vulture网站开始关注了。转折点是什么？
What was the moment where you looked at Brendan or looked at yourself and said, hey, we have something here. We have some traffic on social media. People are listening to the show. Well, that was starting to happen because Vulture picked up on it pretty early. And then I think when we had,
那个时刻是什么时候，你看着布伦丹或者看着自己说：嘿，我们这里搞出名堂了。我们在社交媒体上有流量了，人们在听这个节目。嗯，那个趋势开始出现了，因为Vulture很早就关注了我们。然后我想当我们有，
when I went up to the Bay Area to interview Robin Williams, there was a couple of pretty big shows. When I went up to the Bay Area to interview Robin Williams, there was a couple of pretty big shows. I mean, we had fairly big people social media wise, but I think the Robin interview, because it had never been done before, before that or after. I mean, when he passed,
当我北上湾区采访罗宾·威廉姆斯时，那是一个相当大的节目。当我北上湾区采访罗宾·威廉姆斯时，那是一个相当大的节目。我的意思是，我们在社交媒体上已经有相当大的人物了，但我认为对罗宾的采访，因为以前从来没有人这样做过，无论之前还是之后。我的意思是，当他去世时，
a lot of people were using pieces of that interview because it was a rare thing and it was hard to get him and he was very protected and very insulated in terms of how we were gonna do it. And ultimately I ended up driving up there, I did a lot of those kind of interviews early on where I'd talk in the car on the way. But when I got up there, it was just him in his house and an assistant and I think that people didn't realize
很多人都在使用那次采访的片段，因为这是一次难得的机会，而且很难请到他，他在我们如何进行采访方面受到很强的保护和隔离。最后我开车去了那里，早期我做过很多那种采访，在路上开车时会聊很多。但当我到达那里时，只有他和他的家里人以及一个助理，我想人们并没有意识到
when if Robin was in front of more than two people, or two at least, it was gonna be a show. So when it was just one guy and also a comic and also a guy willing to connect and talk, it was a completely different sort of Robin experience. But if there were one other person there, it would have been wrong because he would have just started jumping around and improvising.
如果罗宾面前有超过两个人，或者至少两个人，那就会变成一场表演。所以当只剩下一个家伙，同时他也是个喜剧演员，也是个愿意连接和交谈的家伙时，那完全是另一种不同的罗宾体验。但如果那里还有另一个人，那就全搞砸了，因为他会开始到处乱跳并即兴表演。
So I think that one really was a big interview in terms of, you know, people- Because people were hearing a quality from him that they were not used to. Yeah, never. It was quite, it was pretty insane, man. Yeah. We'll be right back.
所以我认为那次采访真的是一次重大的采访，就，你知道，人们——因为人们从他身上听到了一种他们不习惯的品质。是的，从来没有。这真是太疯狂了，老兄。是的。我们马上回来。
All right, back to the show. And Mark, now that you've done it for so long, and I mean, it's so impressive, I think Jason said 1,600 episodes or something like that, and it's become part of your identity and all you've done all these years and now you're wrapping it up, talk about that. Are you gonna miss it?
好的，回到节目中。马克，既然你已经做了这么长时间，我的意思是，这太让人印象深刻了，我想杰森说的是1600集左右，这已经成了你身份的一部分，也是你这些年一直在做的事情，现在你要结束它了，谈谈这个吧。你会想念它吗？
Are you going to think like, who am I now and what do I do? I think so. It's a weird thing with the ego in terms of the world we live in and what anyone considers relevance or irrelevance. I was talking to Owen Wilson the other day about it, because I'm on that show with him.
你会想：我现在是谁，我该做什么？我想是的。在自我意识方面，结合我们生活的世界以及任何人对相关性或不相关性的看法，这是一件很奇怪的事情。我前几天还在和欧文·威尔逊谈论这个，因为我和他一起拍那个节目。
And we were talking about stopping the podcast and he quoted some Salinger quote that was like, I don't have the courage to be just unknown. to be just unknown. Or just an average person. But I think what's happening is, and the show has always really been about the arc of my life on the base level, it's been about me and I talk to people. And I think at this point, because we put, the amount of work we do, Brendan and I,
我们当时在谈论停掉播客的事，他引用了一句塞林格的话，大概意思是：我没有勇气做一个完全默默无闻的人。做一个默默无闻的人。或者只是一个普通人。但我认为正在发生的是，而且这个节目一直以来在底层逻辑上都是关于我人生的弧光的，它关乎我，我在和人们交谈。我认为在这一点上，因为我们投入的，我和布伦丹付出的工作量，
it's just always been the two of us, and he's a very specific, very gifted audio producer, takes a lot of time to put these shows together twice a week. And people don't know that, but sometimes, he'll spend hours with an interview, kind of finding a theme, trimming it, you know maybe moving things around.
一直都只有我们两个人，他是一个非常特殊、非常有天赋的音频制作人，每周两次把这些节目拼凑在一起需要花费大量时间。人们并不知道这一点，但有时，他会花几个小时处理一个采访，寻找主题、剪辑，你知道的，也许还会重新调整顺序。
It's so funny how many people have listened to their interview and are like, God I really nailed that thing. It's like it took Brendan four hours. Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well we feel the same way about Robin Bennett and the guys, Michael Terry who work with us.
太搞笑的是，有那么多人听完自己的采访后说：天哪，我那段表现得真好。结果其实布伦丹花了四个小时。是的。对，对，对。好吧，我们对罗宾·贝内特和那些家伙，迈克尔·特里，也就是和我们合作的人，也有同感。
They know the same thing and they're really good at it. We got the best in the biz. Let me answer that real quick, Will. Will, let me just answer Sean real quick. Okay. I apologize. I'm known for interrupting, according to the guy from England.
他们也深知这一点，而且他们真的很擅长。我们拥有业内最棒的团队。让我快速回答一下，威尔。威尔，让我快速回答肖恩一下。好的。我很抱歉。根据那个英国人的说法，我以打断别人而闻名。
That's okay, me too. But the thing is, is like, yeah, I am nervous about the time, but viewing it as a piece of work, as opposed to content, and sort of really assessing the need to keep plowing along just because you can. It was sort of a conversation. We got a deal with a platform, Acast, and that we were in that for years,
没关系，我也是。但问题是，是的，我对时间的流逝感到焦虑，但如果把它当作一件艺术品，而不是单纯的内容，并真正评估一下仅仅因为你能做到就继续埋头苦干的必要性。这其实是一次对话。我们和一个平台Acast达成了一项协议，我们在那里合作多年，
and it kind of made us the money that I think we deserved after working on it so long. And now that's coming to an end. And we were talking before that about winding it down and our agreement has always been like, well, I'm gonna go as long as you go. Whoever cries uncle first, then we'll just honor that. But the truth is, there comes a point with me
这给我们带来了我认为我们长期工作应得的金钱回报。现在这一切即将结束。在此之前，我们一直在讨论慢慢收尾，我们的协议一直是：好吧，你能坚持多久我就坚持多久。谁先举手认输，我们就尊重那个决定。但事实是，对我来说到了某个时刻，
because of the way I do it, where maybe I'd like to have a little bit of a private life. Maybe I'd like to not worry about which pieces and bits of my life are past. I need to kind of bring up in order to satisfy what I do in the audience I've created. That's interesting. Who find a lot of comfort and a lot of,
因为我做这件事的方式，也许我想拥有稍微私密一点的生活。也许我不想再担心我人生的哪些片段和碎屑被重新翻出来。我需要把它们搬出来，以满足我在我所创造的受众面前的需求。这很有趣。他们从中找到了很多慰藉，
I've helped a lot of people unknowingly get sober, not commit suicide, deal with authoritarianism. The way I do it, it was very comforting to a very specific audience. So there's part of me that thinks like, why, I owe them. And they kind of live in your head and that gets a little emotionally exhausting. So I think that by viewing it as a amazing piece of work,
我在不知不觉中帮助了很多人戒酒、打消自杀念头、应对专制主义。我做这件事的方式，对特定的受众来说非常具有慰藉作用。所以我内心的一部分会想：为什么，我亏欠他们的。他们有点活在你的脑海里，这在情感上让人有点精疲力竭。所以我认为，把它看作是一部了不起的艺术品，
you know, 16 years of a thing that never diminished in its quality and always had the arc of me and was always interesting and engaging every episode, that to sort of say, oh, we're done with this part of our lives, it kind of is good for the legacy of the thing as opposed to being one of those people where it's like,
你知道的，16年来从未减损品质、始终贯穿着我的人生弧光、并且每一集都充满趣味和吸引力的作品，对它说“哦，我们人生中的这一部分结束了”，这对这个事物的传奇色彩其实是一件好事，而不是变成那种让人觉得：
is Marin still doing it? That's crazy, you don't wanna be that guy. Right. Right, right, right. But do you, like, what I was going to say was, you know when you hear like an athlete retires and they say you're going to miss the game, and what's funny is they always say, you know,
马伦还在做那个吗？太疯狂了，你可不想成为那种人。没错。没错，没错，没错。但你觉得，我原本想说的是，你知道当你听说某个运动员退役时，他们说你会怀念比赛，有趣的是他们总是说，你知道的，
I'm going to miss the guys, I'm going to miss being in the locker room, I'm going to miss the people that I work. You know, I don't know anything about your relationship with Brendan, other than you mentioned him a bunch, and he was obviously integral to your show. I mean, that relationship is now gonna change. Have you guys talked about that, how that's gonna shift? Well, you know, it's weird.
我会怀念那些队友，我会怀念更衣室，我会怀念一起工作的伙伴。你知道的，除了你经常提到他、他显然对你的节目至关重要之外，我对外你和布伦丹的关系一无所知。我的意思是，这种关系现在要改变了。你们讨论过这个吗，这种关系将如何转变？好吧，你知道，这很奇怪。
I've been working with him since he was 24, and now he's 44. Wow. And, you know, we met at Air America, and he was an associate producer. So, and the very odd thing about Brendan and I is that he's actually, you know, part of my brain. Like, you know, I do these interviews,
我从他24岁时就开始和他合作，现在他44岁了。哇。而且，你知道，我们在美利坚之音认识的，当时他是助理制作人。所以，我和布伦丹之间最奇怪的事情是，他实际上，你知道的，是我大脑的一部分。就像，你知道，我做这些采访，
and then I send them to him. And my memory of them is of whatever I remember that day, but he spends hours with all of them. So I rely on him to remember things. And also he's a very brilliant guy with politics and film. He's really the smartest guy I know. And he's a great producer because he helps me frame things that I'm thinking,
然后我把它们发给他。我对它们的记忆只停留在当天的印象，但他会花几个小时处理所有的采访。所以我依赖他来记住事情。而且他在政治和电影方面是个非常才华横溢的人。他真的是我认识的最聪明的人。他是个伟大的制作人，因为他帮我把我脑中的想法构建成框架，
which is usually intuitive and then he can give it depth. But over the years, it's always been a professional relationship. We're not really in each other's lives. He's more in mind because he hears me talk about it all the time, but we have, it's one of the only relationships
这些想法通常是直觉性的，而他能赋予其深度。但这些年来，这一直是一种职业关系。我们并没有真正介入彼此的生活。他更多地介入了我的生活，因为他总是听到我谈论这些，但我们拥有，这是唯一一种
where the boundaries are healthy. There's a full respect there. We're 50-50 partners and I don't lean on him for personal stuff unless it's really pressing. And we've never had a fight since I've known him once. And it's just, so that relationship, he'll be there for me if I need him, but he needs a break. But I just think, like what you're saying is true though.
边界健康的双向关系。这里有充分的尊重。我们是五五开的合伙人，除非非常紧急，否则我不会在私事上依赖他。而且自从我认识他以来，我们从未吵过架。所以，这种关系，如果我需要他，他会在那里支持我，但他需要休息一下。但我只是觉得，就像你刚才说的那样，确实如此。
This show is a, it's a big part of my social life. It's a big part of my spiritual and soul life in terms of engaging with other humans who are creative humans and really talking about life, which I think is important to do in one's life. But I was doing it also as my job and outlet. I am gonna miss that. And I imagine that I should really give a heads up to my two friends that it's gonna be hard for them
这个节目是，它是我的社交生活很大一部分。它是我的精神和灵魂生活很大一部分，通过与富有创造力的人类进行交往，真正谈论生活，我认为这在一个人的生活中是很重要的。但我也把这当作我的工作和宣泄口。我会想念这一点的。我想我真的应该提前通知我的两个朋友，他们接下来会有一段时间不好过。
for a little while. Do you feel that you're leaving Marc Maron in a better place than where you found him when you started? I hope so because Marc Maron is gonna be 62 years old in September and, you know, I just did, it's weird. And I know you guys have got to, you guys seem to have a,
你觉得你离开时的马克·马伦比你刚开始做的时候要好吗？我希望如此，因为马克·马伦在九月份就要62岁了，你知道的，我刚刚做完，这很奇怪。而且我知道你们肯定，你们似乎拥有，
probably a more expansive work ethic than I do. But, I don't know, I just did a special, you know, that's gonna premiere on HBO August 1st and it's really probably the best work I've done as a comic. I've done this thing for 16 years and I'm very proud of that as a singular thing. And I wouldn't say I'm tired, but I'd like to see where I am
可能比我更宽泛的职业道德。但是，我不知道，我刚刚做了一个特辑，你知道的，将于8月1日在HBO首播，这很可能是作为喜剧演员的我做过最好的作品。我做这件事16年了，作为一个独立的成就，我为此感到非常自豪。我不能说我累了，但我很想看看当我
without these responsibilities a little bit or without them being pressing all the time. I don't know. Yeah, it is, it's an interesting, I mean, yeah, you mentioned that special on HBO and you mentioned Stick with Owen and I loved that film you were in that Justin Kurzel directed The Order of the Udla.
没有这些责任，或者当这些责任不再时刻紧逼时，我会是什么状态。我不知道。是的，这确实是一个有趣的，我的意思是，是的，你提到了HBO的那个特辑，你提到了和欧文合作的《Stick》，我太喜欢你参演的那部由贾斯汀·库泽尔执导的电影《秩序》。
It was just incredible. Amazing. And your career is, Interesting. It's not even ascendant, ascendant doesn't sound as respectful as I mean it to be, but things are great for you. So probably there's a part of this
那简直太不可思议了。太棒了。而且你的事业，很有趣。甚至都不是蒸蒸日上，“蒸蒸日上”听起来没有我想要表达的那么充满敬意，但你的情况现在非常好。所以可能有一部分原因，
while you're winding that down, it's almost because you might not even have time for it anymore because like. Shifting. Yeah, and also it seems like, correct me if I'm wrong, like you're kind of allowing yourself to be a little bit more, in a healthy way, selfish with your life. And you're saying, well, I don't want to lend
当你逐渐结束这个节目时，几乎是因为你可能再也没有时间去做了，因为就像。转变中。是的，而且看起来，如果我错了请纠正我，就像你正在以一种健康的方式，允许自己对自己的生活变得更加“自私”。你说过，我不想再借出
my personal life out anymore and monetize it. I want to keep my power inside and kind of enjoy being me. It sounds like a really healthy place that you're at. That's where I'm trying to get. I don't know if panic will sit in. I'm not great alone. I don't have a wife. I don't have kids.
不再把我的个人生活拿出来博取利益。我想把力量留在内心，享受做自己。这听起来是一个非常健康的状态。这也是我一直在努力达到的。我不知道恐慌会不会袭来。我一个人过得不太好。我没有妻子。我没有孩子。
You got cats, Mark. Yeah, I got a few cats and that's a whole other thing, dude. I don't know what I'm gonna do with Charlie, but anyway, I've got a real fuck of a cat. So. And the hard thing about cats is like, at least kids grow up. The cats are like, they're just gonna be that.
你有猫啊，马克。对，我有几只猫，这完全是另一回事，老兄。我不知道拿查理怎么办，不过总之，我有一只非常混账的猫。所以。养猫最难的一点是，至少孩子会长大。而猫呢，它们永远都会那样。
And there's no teaching it new things or anything. But yeah, I think that's true, Jason. I think that is ultimately what is happening and as you get older, you give less fucks about certain things and the acting and that kind of stuff. The way I see it is that I've been able to do everything I wanted to do only because I did this one thing on my own that got me out in the world.
而且你没法教它新东西什么的。不过对，我觉得那是真的，杰森。我想这最终就是正在发生的事情，随着你年龄的增长，你对某些事情越来越不在乎，比如演戏之类的事情。在我看来，我能够做所有我想做的事情，仅仅是因为我独自做了这一件让我走向世界的事。
And I've somehow managed to remain kind of under the radar. I don't have the weight of celebrity on me. I'm kind of chipping away. But you're on top of the radar with those that you, I would imagine, respect, admire, the audience you've actually been shooting for, you have. And that, I think, is really admirable. Yeah, I mean, I try not to,
而且我不知怎么设法保持了一种默默无闻的状态。我没有名气带来的重压。我一直在慢慢积累。但你在那些你——我想象中——尊重、崇拜的人眼中，在那些你真正想要吸引的观众面前，你其实是站在聚光灯下的，你拥有这些。我觉得这真的很令人钦佩。对，我是说，我尽量不去，
I kinda know exactly who I am and what my, not so much shortcomings are, but there is an element, because I have friends who are big stars in comedy or whatever, and there's always that little party that's like, fuck, why am I not playing arenas? And it's just sort of like, dude, could you imagine the weirdness of doing what you do in an arena? I do a joke about it.
我差不多清楚自己是谁，我的——与其说是缺点，不如说是有那么一个成分，因为我有朋友是喜剧界的大明星什么的，总会有那种小小的心理活动，觉得：靠，为什么我没在体育馆开专场？这就像是，老兄，你能想象在体育馆里做你这种事有多诡异吗？我为此编了个笑话。
I say, like, I think I could play one arena centrally located in the country somewhere and I could bus my fans in. You know, like buses for Marin leaving out of Whole Foods parking lots in these cities. You know. Yeah. That's so funny. But so I do know who I am and I do know one of the reason I am who I am
我说，比如，我觉得我可以在全国某个居中位置的体育馆演一场，我可以把我的粉丝用大巴车接过去。你知道的，就像从这些城市的全食超市（Whole Foods）停车场出发开往马龙（Marin）的大巴。你知道的。对。太搞笑了。不过话说回来，我确实知道我是谁，我也确实知道我之所以成为现在的我，
has something to do with some fears, but maybe those are good. Maybe those are self-protecting, you know? Yeah. So now the question is. Yeah. What question is, what's day to day? What do you want to do? Like if you had your druthers, if it was like, hey man, and what you kind of do, what's the deal?
这和一些恐惧有关，但也许这些恐惧是好事。也许它们是一种自我保护，你知道的？所以现在的问题是。对。问题是，日常生活中是怎样的？你想做什么？如果你能随心所欲，如果就像是，嘿，老兄，你现在这状态，到底是怎么回事？
Is it wake up? Well, I'd like to try to figure out how to enjoy myself. You guys seem to do it. So what's the path to that? Are you going to learn how to paint? Are you gonna like learn how to, are you gonna paint? Are you gonna learn how to surf? Well look, I do a lot of things. You got guitars.
是醒来之后吗？嗯，我想试着弄清楚怎么让自己过得开心。你们似乎都做到了。那通往这点的途径是什么？你要去学画画吗？你要去学，你会去画画吗？你要去学冲浪吗？好吧，你看，我做很多事情。你有吉他。
I've been playing guitar with people. I'm playing, you know, I get together and sometimes I do music shows. I've found the courage to sing in front of people and that's sort of daunting and interesting. But you know what I really like to learn how to do, and I don't know how to do it. You know, like when I act, you know, I think I do okay with it.
我一直在和别人一起弹吉他。我在弹，你知道的，我会聚在一起，有时我会做音乐演出。我找到了在人们面前唱歌的勇气，这有点令人畏缩也有趣。但你知道我真正想学的是什么，而我还不会。你知道的，就像我演戏的时候，你知道，我觉得我演得还行。
You do it, you're great. Well, that's nice. You are good. And I just did a feature, an indie feature where I'm the lead and I kind of manned up and pulled that up. We'll see if it gets out anywhere. Nice. But there's this thing where...
你演了，你很棒。哦，这太好了。你确实不错。我刚拍了一部电影，一部独立电影，我是主角，我鼓起勇气把它扛下来了。我们会看看它最终能不能上映。不错。但有这么个事……
Is that the one with Judy Greer? She's in it, but Lily Gladstone's in it, Sharon Stone, Alan Ruck. Awesome. Michael McKean. That's called in memoriam? Yeah, dude, it's funny, and I watched a final cut, and let me ask you this, two questions about acting
那是朱迪·格里尔（Judy Greer）演的那部吗？她演了，但莉莉·格莱斯顿（Lily Gladstone）也演了，还有莎朗·斯通、艾伦·瑞克（Alan Ruck）。太棒了。迈克尔·麦基恩（Michael McKean）。那部叫《悼词》（In Memoriam）吗？对，老兄，这很有趣，我看了最终剪辑版，让我问你这个，关于表演的两个问题
since we're here. When you watch yourself, are you always sort of like, ah, fuck, why'd I, you know? I could've, you know. I mean, you can. I could've, you know. You know. Like, you know, I mean, you can watch the whole movie, but some part of you is really focused on like, why'd I do that with my eye?
既然我们在这儿。当你看着自己的时候，是不是总会有种，啊，靠，我当时为什么，你知道的？我本可以，你知道的。我是说，你可以。我本可以，你知道的。你知道的。就像，你知道的，我是说，你可以看完整部电影，但你内心某一部分真正关注的是，为什么我当时那个眼神要那样？
You know, like. I will say that the fact that you're doing that, that you're watching and you're being honest with yourself and your, that will make you an incredible actor. I've learned so much from seeing how bad I am on things and adjusting for the next job. But don't people say you're good though?
你知道，就像。我要说的是，你现在在做这件事，你在观看并对你自己和你的表现诚实，这会让你成为一个不可思议的演员。我通过看到自己在某些方面有多烂并为下一份工作做出调整，学到了很多。但难道别人不说你演得好吗？
Aren't they telling you that it's good? Yeah, but you know. It doesn't matter what they say. But are we right? Yes, I'm saying you need to, I think you need to watch yourself. And there's so many talented actors that I work with that never watch themselves because they're afraid
他们难道没告诉你这很好吗？对，但你知道的。别人怎么说并不重要。但我们是对的吗？是的，我的意思是，你需要，我认为你需要看自己的表现。有那么多与我合作的天才演员从不看自己的表演，因为他们害怕
that they're bad, yet they're so good. And I keep saying, you're denying yourself like this great treat. But Jason, I think that you have a unique ability. I really mean this, and I don't know if it's because you've been doing it since you were a little kid, so it's just so ingrained into who you are, but you have a really good ability to separate
他们演得不好，然而他们却那么优秀。我一直说，你剥夺了自己这样一个巨大的乐趣。但杰森，我认为你有一种独特的能力。我是说真的，我不知道这是否是因为你从小就在演戏，所以它已经融入了你的骨子里，但你确实有一种非常好的能力，能够把
and be objective. You really, really do. It's a great quality. And so you're able to go and look at stuff and now also because you have that, because you direct. So your ability to be objective about your place in the story, understanding where you are, is I think unique, I don't think everybody has that.
而且很客观。真的，真的是这样。这是一个非常棒的特质。所以你能够去观察事物，而且现在也因为你具备这一点，因为你做导演。所以我认为，你能客观地看待自己在故事中的位置、理解自己处于何种境地，这非常独特，我觉得不是每个人都有这种能力的。
I know, just thinking about what Jason does like with the directing and then with the acting, like I'm getting anxiety thinking about his career. So. So. Like I can't even fucking wrap my brain around it. You know, like, here's the question that is kinda eating at me. It's like, I was sitting with Judy at some junket for stick
我知道，一想到杰森在导演和表演方面所做的事，光是想想他的职业生涯我就开始焦虑了。所以。所以。简直让我脑子都转不过弯来。你知道的，有个问题一直在折磨着我。当时我正和朱迪坐在一起参加某个宣传活动
cause she's got a part in that too. And she said to me, she said, the way you handled that character was very unique cause most people would have went broad with it. And I said to her, I said, I don't think I know how to go broad. And she goes, I don't think you do either. So some part of my brain is like, I gotta figure know how to go broad. And she goes, I don't think you do either. So some part of my brain is like,
因为她在那部剧里也有个角色。她对我说，她评价我处理那个角色的方式非常独特，因为大多数人都会把这个角色演得很夸张。我对她说，我说我好像不知道怎么演夸张的角色。她接道，我觉得你确实不知道。所以我的脑子里某一部分就在想，我得弄明白怎么才能演得夸张。然后她又说，我觉得你也不知道。所以我的脑子里某一部分就在想，
I gotta figure out how to get broad. How do I become a broad comic actor? I don't have it in me. It's so funny, by the way, I was just thinking, I saw a video on social media this morning. Sean, I don't know who, I think the play posted it of you just playing piano. Oh yeah, I saw that too.
我得弄清楚怎么才能把角色演得夸张。我怎么才能成为一个夸张的喜剧演员呢？我身上根本没有这细胞。说实话，这太逗了，我刚才正在想，我今天早上在社交媒体上看到一个视频。肖恩，我不知道是谁，好像是哪个剧组发出来的，是你弹钢琴的视频。哦对，我也看到了。
Within the last couple of days. Yeah, the Gershwin. Yeah, the Gershwin thing. And Sean's about to, he's in London, he's about to do his show on the West End. Good night Oscar. At the Tabasco or the? At the barbecue.
就在这几天。对，格什温的曲子。对，格什温那个事。肖恩正准备去，他在伦敦，他马上要在西区演他的剧了。致美好的奥斯卡。在塔巴斯科还是？在巴贝库。
At the barbecue, sorry. At the, and you're just sitting down, it's you're playing, you're not playing in front of anybody and you just start playing. And honest to God, and not to embarrass you, I thought, this fucking guy is so fucking talented. Yeah. No, it's true, and I thought, like,
在巴贝库，抱歉。在，然后你就在那儿坐着，你在弹琴，你不是在任何人面前表演，你就这么开始弹了。说实话，真不是想让你尴尬，当时我想，这混蛋也太特么有才了。对。不，确实如此，当时我想，
I couldn't do that if you gave me a million tries. Yeah, you got it. And you know what I mean? In 10 years. And I'm just thinking, like, god damn it, like, what am I doing? I'm fixing my bike in the garage this week. I'm going to order a piano on Amazon, right? I literally went to get a new wrench at the hardware store and then rode back and couldn't figure out how to use it
就算你让我试上一百万次，我也做不到。对，你懂的。你知道我的意思吗？在10年里。我当时就在想，操，那我到底在干嘛？我这周在车库修自行车呢。我要去亚马逊订个钢琴，对吧？我literally（简直）跑去五金店买了个新扳手，然后骑车回来，却根本不知道怎么用它
And was trying to get them to raise my handlebars and for a half hour before you called the guy to fix it, right? No, I I did it. I got the scar super I did it wrong and then my seat kept going down anyway, and Sean's there playing making beautiful art and I was like Oh god damn it. That's really nice. I think we all have gifts and we're all lucky enough to be able to share them. Yeah, it is pretty great, Mark.
还想让人家帮我把车把调高，就在你打电话找人来修之前，对吧？没有，我弄了。我受了点轻伤，超——我弄错了，结果我的座位还是直往下掉，不管怎样，肖恩在那儿弹琴，创作出美丽的艺术，而我当时就想，哦，操。这真的很不错。我觉得我们每个人都有天赋，而且我们都很幸运能够把它们分享出来。对，这真的很棒，马克。
Whatever your innate talent is, you have found a lane for it, a platform for it, a place to apply it, and doing such good for so many that listen to you. I'm very happy for you that you are deciding to spend a little of that on yourself and reinvesting in your... And leave on your terms. And also, and I reject the idea, just before, I also reject the idea. And I know you say it because it's kind of a funny one line, like people thought, well, if Mark can do it, I can do it.
不管你与生俱来的天赋是什么，你都为它找到了一个赛道，一个平台，一个施展的地方，并且为那么多聆听你节目的人做了这么多好事。我真为你高兴，你决定把其中一小部分精力留给自己，重新投资到你的……并且按照你自己的方式退场。而且，我还反对这种观点，就在刚才，我也反对这种观点。我知道你这么说是因为这听起来像一句好笑的俏皮话，就像人们觉得，好吧，既然马克能做到，那我也可以。
That's not true at all. I think the opposite is true. I think that you inspired people to. Oh, that's nice. It's true, and you grew this medium so that dumb-dumbs like us could do it. And that your tone and your quality and your honesty and your vulnerability
事实根本不是这样的。我觉得恰恰相反。我觉得你激励了人们去……哦，太好了。这是真的，你开创了这种媒介，所以像我们这样的笨蛋才能做这件事。而且你的基调、你的品质、你的诚实以及你的脆弱
was a viable format. But I think the other thing I wanna know is, because comedy, look, I watch my new special and I like it. I have complete control out of that craft, and it's the best work I've done. I know that. That's great. And with this thing, but with comedy and with podcasting, it's all driven improvisationally. It's all going to create itself in real time.
是一种行之有效的模式。但我觉得我另一件想知道的事是，因为喜剧，你看，我看了我的新专场，我很喜欢。我对那种技艺有着完全的掌控力，那是我做过最好的作品。我知道这一点。这太棒了。还有这个节目，但对于喜剧和播客来说，这一切都是即兴驱动的。一切都将在实时中自然而然地诞生。
And with acting, that's different. So then all of a sudden you got a script and you make choices and all that stuff. But I don't know really where, none of my imagination goes into creating fiction or creating things outside of myself. Everything I do is impulsive and comes from, you know, the need to connect.
而表演则不同。所以突然之间你拿到了剧本，然后你做出选择诸如此类的事情。但我真的不知道，我的想象力没有一点是用在创造虚构或是创造我自身之外的事物上的。我做的每一件事都是冲动使然，并且源于……你知道的，那种连接的需求。
So I'm kind of curious, do I have creativity that is more disciplined that I can apply in another way? That's the big mystery. Can I apply my talents to something that isn't essentially marked? Have you ever sat down and written? Have you ever, other than writing jokes? Yeah, I write every week.
所以我有点好奇，我有没有那种更具纪律性、可以应用到其他地方的创造力呢？这就是最大的谜团。我能把我的才华应用到一些本质上不是“马克式”的东西上去吗？你曾经坐下来写过东西吗？你曾经，除了写笑话之外？对，我每周都写。
I don't love writing, you know, it than writing jokes? Yeah, I write every week. I don't love writing. It's exhausting. But I write a thing every week, but reflections that are sort of poetic, and I put that out into the world, and I've done the writing. But my comedy is sort of formed on stage in real time until it sort of sets,
我不喜欢写作，你知道的，除了写笑话之外？对，我每周都写。我不喜欢写作。这太让人筋疲力尽了。但我每周都会写点东西，是一些有点诗意的感悟，然后我把它发表到世界上，我也确实写过。但我的喜剧基本上是在舞台上实时成型的，直到它差不多定型，
and then I leave room for new things to happen. Like I did the special, and I usually start with like an hour and 45 minutes that I tour with for a year and a half. And then three weeks before I got to shoot, I got to get it down to like 70 minutes and figure out what the callbacks are. And then I leave a little open space
然后我才会留出空间让新的东西发生。就像我做专场一样，我通常从巡演一年半的一个小时四十五分钟的内容开始。然后在录制前的三个星期，我得把它压缩到大约70分钟，并找出那些前后呼应的包袱。然后我会留出一小片空白空间
for things to drop in the days before, or even that night so it keeps it alive. And, but I'm very confident in that craft and I'm very confident in this talking on the mic thing. But like with acting or I've set in motion, I'm gonna direct a film based on my buddy, Sam Lipsight's book. And hopefully that'll happen.
好让在演出前几天甚至当晚临时蹦出点新东西，这样能保持它的活力。而且，我对那种技艺非常有信心，对这种对着话筒说话的事情也很有信心。但比如表演，或者我已经开始着手准备的，我要导演一部基于我的好友萨姆·利普西特的书改编的电影。希望这能顺利进行吧。
But that's a little daunting and scary, but I guess I'm not afraid to take the chances. No, it sounds like, of course you've got creativity. What are you talking about? You're doing it all. Yeah, in answer to what I think your question is about the application of what you here too, for have been doing, which is basically freestyling,
但这有点让人畏惧和害怕，不过我想我并不害怕去冒险。不，听起来，你当然有创造力。你在说什么呢？你一直在做这些啊。对，为了回答我认为你所提的问题，关于如何运用你一直以来在这里所做的事情——也就是基本上是自由发挥、
improvising, you are coming first and then the words follow, right? That's your writing for standup, your freestyling on the microphone, your podcast, how do you apply that same level of accuracy, authenticity into something that is, by its own definition, pre-written, right? A movie, a script.
即兴创作，你总是先有行动然后文字才随之出现，对吧？那是你写单口喜剧的方式，你在麦克风前的自由发挥，你的播客，你如何将同样水准的精准度、真实感应用到那种本身就定义为“预先写好”的东西上去呢？比如一部电影、一个剧本。
Or outside of myself, yeah. How do you find that level of Mark Maron in acting? I will say that you are allowed, when you take on a character, to make that character simply just another part of who Mark Maron is. You know, there are goal posts. You're far right, far left of who Mark Maron is, and then you just find whatever version that character
或者我自身之外的事物，对吧。你如何在表演中找到那种“马克·马龙”的水准呢？我要说的是，当你接下一个角色时，你是被允许让这个角色简单地成为“马克·马龙”本色的一部分的。你知道的，这中间是有门柱的。你可以处于马克·马龙本色的最右边或最左边，然后你只需在这些门柱之内，找到那个最接近你的角色的版本。所以你依然在做马克·马龙。只不过台词是提前写好的，而你得找到那个适合这些台词的你自己。所以你某种程度上依然在展现你是谁，并且应该仍然能够从中找到一些乐趣。对，我懂那个部分，就是你如何在自己体内
is closest to you inside of those goal posts. So you're still being Mark Manning. It's just the words are written beforehand and you gotta find the version of you that fits those words. And so you're still kind of, you're still exhibiting who you are and should still be able to find some enjoyment from that. Yeah, I get that part where you kind of turn things off
关闭某些东西或者开启某些东西。我在表演中能理解这一点。我的问题是，我能做一些别的事吗，比如如果我当导演，我没有这方面的词汇库，我没有自己的风格，所以那完全在我自身之外，我只能去摸索那到底是什么。我能吗，我可以吗？
or turn things on within you. I get that with the acting. My question is, can I do something, like if I direct, I don't have a vocabulary for that, I don't have a style, so that's completely outside of me and I'm just gonna have to figure out what that is. Can I, could I? You don't need to do that on the first one.
你不需要在第一部作品里就做到那些。只要运用你的品味，坐在那里看着别人的工作成果，然后对这个说“好”，对那个说“不”，这个再多一点，那个再多一点。导演是剧组里唯一一个没有具体活儿干的人，所以你其实根本不需要做什么。我并不是说这就是当导演的正确方式，但我合作过一百万个这样工作的导演了。
Just exercise taste and just sit there and watch the results of other people's work and say yes to this, no to that, little more of this, little more of that. It is the one person on the set that doesn't have a job, so you don't really actually need to do anything. I'm not suggesting that's the right way to be a director, but I've worked with a million that work that way.
这非常普遍，所以你不需要被诸如“我得做一大堆破事”这种想法压垮。你可以先学会走路再跑步，就坐在那儿，当个品味仲裁者，你知道吗？对。好吧，我会这么做的。对，你能做到，你有着极高的品味。他妈的，我今天从杰森这儿学到了很多。
It's very common, so you need not be overwhelmed with, I gotta do a bunch of shit. You can walk before you run and just sit there and just be the arbiter of taste, you know? Right. Okay, I will do that. Yeah, you can do that, you've got great taste. Fuck, I've learned a lot from Jason today.
对，我听着一些神奇的……你一定饿坏了。这人是谁啊？我下周要开始做我自己的播客了，我想跟你们说来着。我在听呢，你在开玩笑吧？我下周要开始做我自己的播客了。我想跟你们说说这事。我在听呢。你在开玩笑吧？我等不及了。
Yeah, I'm listening to some amazing, you gotta be starved. Who's this guy? I'm starting my own podcast next week, I wanted to tell you guys about. I'm listening to it, are you kidding me? I'm starting my own podcast next week. I wanted to tell you guys about it. I'm listening to it. Are you kidding me? I can't wait.
我靠。我们花了300期节目才终于让你听进去了。我终于熬出头了。等等，要不是因为马克，你知道我的意思吗？这样如何？这是我经历过的第一个采访，第一个嘉宾，我竟然连一个问题都没问到。
Holy shit. It took us 300 episodes to get through to you. I've arrived. Wait, if it wasn't for Mark, you know what I mean? How about this? This is the first interview, a first guest I've ever had that I didn't get to one single question.
而且我们已经超出一小时整整六分钟了。所以这绝对是对你的证明，马克·马龙先生，你太会侃了，知道自己在做什么，让对话一直持续下去。不过我能为肖恩分享一个故事吗？请便。好的，请吧。那么肖恩，你还在吗？在呢。他这不来了嘛。
And we're already six minutes over one hour. So that is a testament to you, Mr. Mark Maron, knowing the gift of gab, knowing what you're doing, keeping the conversation going. Can I share one story though for Sean? Please. Yes, please. So Sean, are you still here? Yep. There he is.
我去上个洗间，我回来了。好吧，他刚才谈到了那个做短期全面检查的医生。对，太对了。我去做其中一次老头子体检，我猜大概是去年吧，现在做前列腺检查，他们只做验血了。
I took a bathroom break, I'm back. Well, he talked about the doctor that did the full examination for the short term. Yeah, so true. I went into one of my old guy physicals, I guess it was probably last year, and now for the prostate test, they only do the blood test.
所以，你知道的。手指检查取消了？对，呃，我当时不知道这个，所以，你知道，我以为——手指检查取消了？对，就是这样，我不知道。所以那家伙说，我说，呃，我们还要做那个手指检查吗？对我来说可别。然后他说，他说了，不，不，我们不再做那个了。
And so, you know. The finger's gone? Right, well, I didn't know that, so, you know, I think- The finger's gone? Right, well, that's, I didn't know that. So the guy said, I said, well, are we gonna do the finger thing? Not for me, it's not. And then he goes, he says, no, no, we don't do that anymore.
你知道的，他们现在用血检。我说，呃，那这管用吗？我是说，你觉得结果准确吗？他就像是，对，不，我们只做验血。他说，如果你想要的话，我也可以做另一个。所以我心想，天哪，我要是做了会感觉好点。那得另加50美元。如果你们做了，我会感觉更好。
You know, they do it with the blood. I'm like, well, is that effective? I mean, you find that the results, he's like, yeah, no, we just do the blood test. He says, I can do the other thing if you want. So I'm like, boy, I would feel better. That was 50 bucks extra. I would feel better if you did.
所以我向医生要求了一次“手指马杀鸡”。对，他照做了。他真的照做了，我的诊断结果是情况不明。他需要重新把手伸进去。你说，你进去之前怎么不顺便套个戒指呢？他说他想让你下周再去一次。对，对，他现在就在这儿呢。
So I requested a finger bang from the doctor. Yeah, and he did that. He did, and my diagnosis is it's not clear. He needed to go back in. You said, why don't you go ahead and toss a ring on too before you get in there. He said he'd like to see you again next week. Yeah, yeah, he's here now.
不过你稍微有点疑病症，就像我也有点一样。对，好吧，我是跟一个医生父亲一起长大的，所以这是获取关注的真实方式。比如，你知道，我觉得我得了癌症。所以，但是好吧，我能掌控，我有一个，你知道的，我能掌控它，这种事不那么常发生了。而当它真的发生时，往往影响很深。就像，你知道的，我通常可以对自己说，只要再等几天，它大概就
You're a little bit of a hypochondriac though, like I am a little bit. Yeah, well, I grew up with a doctor father, so it was a real way to get attention. Like, you know, I think I have cancer. So, but yeah, I've got a handle on, I got a, you know, I got a, I got a handle on it, you know, it doesn't happen as much. And when it does happen, it runs pretty deep. Like, you know, like I can usually say like, just wait a couple of days, it'll probably
会消失了，诸如此类。但如果我真的陷入那种“我觉得我得了癌症”的想法中，我会一路钻牛角尖到底，然后坐在我的床上一边流汗，一边想象着虚无。这叫聪明和富有创造力。那种能够在脑海中创造出这些剧本的能力，实在是……哦当然，这就是我使用想象力的方式。全都是由恐慌和恐惧驱动的。
go away, that kind of stuff. But if I really lock into, I think I have cancer, I'll go all the way through it and I'll sit in my bed and just sweat, you know, anticipating the nothingness. That's called intelligence and being creative. The ability to sort of like create these scenarios in your brain that are just so. Oh sure, that's how I use my imagination. Just all driven by panic and fear.
我真的很想把它释放出来。你知道谁没有恐慌吗？笨蛋。也许吧，你知道的，创造出这种世界末日般的场景需要很高的智商。我知道，但当他们不谈论那种幸福的无知时，难道他们看起来不比我们更快乐一点吗？当他们不谈论QAnon阴谋论时？
I'd really like to free it up. You know who doesn't have panic? Dummies. Could be, you know, it takes a lot of intelligence to like create this like fucking doomsday scenario. I know, but don't they seem a little more happier than we are when they're not talking about blissful ignorance? When they're not talking about QAnon?
这种快乐没有那么深刻。觉得呢？没有。好吧，这是一种投射，但你知道的，坚持这样想吧。马克，我们爱你，我们谢谢你。太不可思议了。你是最棒的。
The happiness is not as profound. How about that? No. Okay. Well, that's a projection, but you know, hold on to it. Mark, we love you and we thank you. Incredible. You're the greatest.
谢谢你们，伙计们。我真的很感激。而且你们俩也做得很棒。谢谢你，伙计。非常感谢。请继续保持创作，你们会考虑至少也许每年做一次专场之类的吗？只是为了，我不是指那些精彩的专场。
Thanks guys. I really appreciate it. And you guys are doing great. Thank you, man. Well thank you. You please keep on jamming and will you consider at least maybe doing a special once a year or something? Just to, and I don't mean the incredible specials on.
对，对，带着《WTF》回归，给人们更新近况。嗯，我得想想，我觉得还有其他途径。你知道的，也许这就像是《大卫·莱特曼秀》的播客版，你知道我的意思吗？他一年大概做六期那种。我可以做到那样，但随后你就会有点像，到底是谁……你知道的，我的制作人，如果没有他我其实做不了太多，但我觉得存在这样一种世界：
Yeah, yeah, come back with WTF and give people updates. Well I have to figure out, I think there's other ways. You know, maybe it's the podcast version of The Letterman Show, you know what I mean? Where he does like six a year or something. I could do that but then you're kind of like who's, you know my producer, and I don't really do much without him, but I think there is a world
我可以至少在稍微休息一段时间后，每周上一次麦，就只是和大家聊聊天，甚至不需要观众。那也许会发生，我不知道。我们想要，我们需要，请务必这么做。谢谢老兄。对，对。好吧，伙计们，行吧。非常感谢你们，伙计们。
where I could at least maybe after a little time off get on the mic once a week just to talk without people. That might happen, I don't know. We want it, we need it, please do it. Thanks buddy. Yeah, yeah. Okay fellas, all right. Thanks a lot you guys.
祝你们好运，我的朋友，谢谢你们的到来。谢谢马克。保重啊伙计们，肖恩，祝你的演出顺利。祝你演出成功。谢谢老兄，谢谢，非常感激。再见。再见马克。天哪，那个马克·马龙，我是说，太棒了。肖恩，不幸的是，
Best of luck to you my friend, thanks for coming. Thanks Mark. Take care you guys, good luck with the show Sean. Break a leg. Thank you pal, thank you, appreciate it. Bye. Bye Mark. Boy that Mark Maron, I mean, so Willie, Sean, unfortunately,
你从来没去过他的节目，但是威利，难道不觉得，你只要坐在那儿，听着他说话，他就会把你带进那样一种状态里，就好像：哦，我只想把关于我的一切都告诉你。你知道吗？他太有魅力了。他简直就像个治疗师，你知道吧？
you never did his show, but Willie, doesn't it sort of, you just sit there, you listen to him and he just kind of rocks you into this place of like, oh, I just want to tell you everything about me. You know? He's just so charming. He's almost like a therapist, you know?
对，但又不会显得过分殷勤。他总是自己先敞开心扉，而且他身上有一种很棒的特质。他只是开始说话，然后你们就自然而然地聊了起来。你会忘记你正在录节目，然后突然之间，你就在跟他讲述那些你以前从未以这种方式谈论过的事情。
Yeah, but without being solicitous. He just kind of goes first and there's just like this nice quality to him. He just starts talking and you're just having a conversation. You forget that you're doing it and all of a sudden you're telling him stuff that you haven't ever talked about in that way before.
对，说到天赋，这真的是天赋。就像那是他的天赋，你知道的——威利，你能这么说真是太好了，但我们其实真的都有天赋，而他的天赋就是能够持续不断地让对话进行下去，保持有趣，永远充满好奇心。他对遇到的每一个人都充满好奇
Yeah, it's a really talk about gifts though. Like that's his gift is like, you know, like it was very nice of you to say that Willie, but like we all really do have gifts and his gift is to just be able to constantly keep a conversation going, be interesting, never not be curious. He's always curious about every single person
而且这真的是一场高水平的对话。你会被深深吸引进去。对，我很高兴他至少永远都能保留他的单口喜剧来作为一种……我很期待他的新单口专场。那肯定会很棒。对，对，对，就是那个，他刚才提到了，但为了确保没错，它叫《惊恐》（Panicked），
and it's really an intelligent conversation. You get sucked in. Yeah, I'm glad that at least he will always have his standup to sort of just be. I'm excited for his new standup special. That's gonna be great. Yeah, yeah, yeah, that is, he mentioned it earlier, but just to make sure, it's called Panicked,
将于8月1日在HBO播出。之后它会在Max上流媒体播放。我是他超级大的粉丝。对，我也是。他一直是个这么好的家伙。我想，你知道，肖恩，你提到了天赋，他有这个，杰森，我们谈到了你的天赋，你也有你的天赋，老兄。我觉得，你知道，肖恩你提到了天赋，然后他有这个，杰森，我们谈到了你的天赋，然后肖恩——哦哦，埃里克·孔普说埃里克·孔普觉得你很棒
and it's gonna be on HBO August 1st. And then it'll stream on the Max after that. But such a big fan of his. Yeah, same here. He's always been such a good dude. And I figure, you know, Shon, you mentioned the gifts, and he has that, and Jason, we talked about your gifts, and you have your gifts dude and I figured you know, Shawn you mentioned the gifts and you know He has that and Jason and we talked about your gifts and Shawn Uh-oh, Eric Comps said Eric Comps is good for you
而且我不知道，我什么天赋也没有，但你知道吗？希望有一天我也能处于这样一个位置：我能够买得起一个天赋！那可真逗。再见！再见！Smart Less，再见！格兰特·特里、罗布·阿姆贾夫和本尼特·巴巴戈。这一集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
And I don't know, I wasn't given any gifts, but you know what? Hopefully one day I'll be in a position where I'll be able to BUY ONE! That was pretty good. Yeah. Bye! Bye! Smart Less Yeah, bye! Grant Terry, Rob Armjarv, and Bennett Barbago. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我不知道，我没收到任何礼物，但你知道吗？希望有一天我能有能力买一个！那挺不错的。再见！再见！Smart Less，再见！格兰特·特里、罗布·阿尔姆亚夫和贝内特·巴尔巴戈。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。